Has anybody checked in on Jesse Lee Peterson recently? What content?
Well, he's met his intellectual match finally. >> Okay.
Stop. This is amazing. Yeah. Throw this up. >> What's wrong
with the blacks? >> I don't know. >> What's wrong
with the blacks? >> I don't know. Do you know the story
of Stan Lee in in Canada? >> Not that I'm aware of right
now. What is >> So, there was a man in Canada. This Asian
She didn't just say there's nothing wrong with the blacks. Okay,
I'm >> Are you I read that you are a liberal.
>> Let's go. She got one. She knows something. Let's go.
Oh my god. Yes, she is aware she's a liberal. Holy. I thought
we might go this entire interview without her
Has anybody checked in on Jesse Lee Peterson recently? Is there
Jesse Lee Peterson content that might be out there that some
people might be excited about? Is it is there Jesse Peterson?
>> Jesse Lee Peterson himself.
>> What content? >> What content? Well, he's met
his intellectual match finally. Okay, let me tell you. >> Stop
it. Do I know about this?
Did you tell me about this? >> Yeah, link in the com link
in Discord. I could have sworn I told you about this, did I not?
>> Oh my goodness. I don't know why I thought this was
going to be reacting to Jordan Peterson.
What? >> No. I I thought something completely >> People
have referred to one of the two participants as the female Jordan
>> Okay, stop. This is amazing. Yeah, throw this [__]
up.
>> I'm calling Jesse. By the way, >> we got uh
>> I don't know if you guys saw this, but JLP interviews
notoite
liberal influencer Kyla Turner joins Jesse Lee
>> I have with me Kyla Turner.
She is a political commentator
and social media influencer.
Her channel is called Not So
what's that?
>> Not so arudate. What does that mean?
>> Means scholarly or learned.
>> Yeah. It's a joke. >> Are you a scholar person?
>> Well, I'm not so aridate. So, >> Oh, you're not
the cheek. Welcome to the >> I like science. Thank you
for having me. >> You should just say I like science. >> I
like science. Thank you for having me. She likes science. Okay.
>> Please, please make sure that Jesse is the person who
looks on this on this
>> I trust me, I think there's plenty of to go around.
We can >> Kyla is very smart. Okay. She is smart. She knows
how to do research. She knows how to make an argument.
Yeah, >> I don't think she thinks on her feet very quickly,
but she should be prepared to make herself look smarter than
JLP. >> Yeah, we'll see. >> Important to you?
>> That's a good question. Um,
my husband. >> Wait, hold on. Oh, what's important to you?
I missed the question. >> You obey him?
>> Oh, wait. Did I just go back?
>> You're a person. >> Sorry, I went forward instead
of backwards. every day. So,
>> welcome to >> I like science. Thank you for having
me. >> What's important to you? >> What's important?
>> That's a good question. Um,
my husband,
uh, my faith,
and
trying to conduct
>> Probably like the top three. Yeah. >> And when
you say my husband, do you you obey your husband?
>> Yeah, sure. You obey him? >> Yeah, a lot of the
time. >> Nice.
And so are you a Christian?
>> I am. >> And why are you a Christian?
>> Uh I always say uh he keeps giving me a reason uh to
believe. Uh it's more like how could I not be is kind of more
my my >> Right on. You um do you believe that human beings
are in a fallen state?
Uh like the >> what? Uh listen, >> that's the name
of his show. >> Oh, I never
people are people are laughing about he always keeps giving me
a reason. It's like I I'm sorry. He's probably asking a deeper
question there. I don't know. It's whatever, man. >> Logically.
Uh yeah. Yeah. Like we're in sin. True. >> Yeah. Amazing,
huh?
Can you >> I mean, not not amazing. Kind of not >> Can
you overcome that?
>> Maybe call her. I got it saved. Well, sort of. Not on
your own. >> That's for sure.
>> And for those who don't know that, why not on your own?
You can overcome it.
>> Well, if we're being theological, right, as a Christian,
all fall short of the glory of God. That's kind of like the premise
is like we all sin. We're all in sin. We all need Jesus. Uh that's
the that's the reason why we're not supposed to judge each other
is cuz we all got planks. Um, I think if you're if you don't
believe in God, I think that gets more complicated. Um, which
I'm empathetic to. Uh, but if if we're talking just about Christians,
sorry, you're not Jesus and none of us are. That's kind of the
point. >> Yeah. I The one thing that we're not supposed
to do, well, number two, two primary thing we should do. Love
God with all our heart, soul, and might along with nothing else
or no one else. And to love our neighbors,
to love one another. And those are the two things that people
don't do. They don't love God,
a lot of Christians, and they judge one another. They don't love
their
>> Have you noticed that?
>> I uh I feel like especially it feels like increasingly
there's a lot of
>> Um Yeah. In America. >> And why is that? It is.
It's out of control right now.
Multiple factors. It depends on which lens you want to talk about,
why there's so much hatred. We could talk about social media
and its impacts on radicalization and the way we view each other.
Um, could talk about wealth disparity. We could talk about theology.
Um, I think the reasons why we all hate each other is probably
complicated. And I think the worst part about hatred is we all
feel we all feel justified in it. We're like, yeah, hatred's
bad, but like mine's fair. I think that's that's the problem
with it, right? >> Absolutely.
That's amazing. Huh.
>> And so >> is he gonna That was like a non-answer
and he's not going to follow up and go down any of those. He's
like, "Cool. You just said some amazing." Anyway, I'm going to
ask the next question. >> Um, do you have anger
>> And is it possible to be a child of God, a daughter
of God or son, and have
>> I mean, Jesus had anger. So, yeah, if we're taking his
mom. >> No, he didn't. >> No. What did he do to the
people in the temple? the money lenders. Wasn't that wasn't that
like uh there's like the painting of him with like a whip. Am
I crazy thinking about that? >> Shut up.
>> You can have anger. There's there's sinful anger and
there's righteous anger. Um right. Jesus took a temple of whip
of cords to the temple.
>> It's a thing I referenced.
>> I'm almost as smart as Kyla. Damn.
>> No, but she made the distinction.
What distinction?
>> Um the difference between like the anger that we feel
like I could take justice I could take justice into my own hands
that won't be justice. Justice is like God's justice is the right
justice. Jesus is God. So when you say Jesus has anger that doesn't
justify your anger. You're like don't put yourself on par. >> Sure.
Sure. Um, I would also say like,
yeah, it doesn't doesn't justify anything, right? That would
be a part of Jesus being like, uh, not not perfect. Like the
idea that God became a human to to experience imperfection.
>> I assume it would be something along those lines. >> Uh,
I just want to play a soundboard real quick. I was looking for
that in the background. >> Just looks really smart. >> Thank
you. Thank you, Kyla. Thank you. >> Oh, I know the context
of that where she's like, "Yeah, okay." And just looks really
smart. >> Yeah, just looks really smart. >> Yeah,
thank you. >> Like really smart. >> Like really smart.
>> Very angry. [__] on you. >> Violent
even. Um so there there's a space for righteous anger. Um but
>> there's also a lot of anger that I think happens that
of course I'm guilty of >> Oh, also Donnie here, thank
you for the gifted sub to Moonray Murray. Let's go. Thank you.
Thank you. >> Whatot that's not righteous. It's petty.
It's um vengeful.
And so
what's the difference between >> I am always angry. I'm
human
>> anger and and nonrighteous anger. >> That's tough.
I think there's a lot of prayer that has to go into that. I think
for example when people violate justice I think a lot of righteous
anger can emerge. Um, and I think the problem is that what often
happens is when
>> wouldn't it wouldn't the answer be like there is no
such thing for humans as righteous anger that humans are the
people who judge that
>> anger you know about the of the Ukrainian girl I imagine.
>> Yeah. Horrible story.
>> That's an evil story. What happened to her was evil.
>> Yeah. It's tragic and there's a lot of people righteously
angry about that. But the problem is that I think the news tries
to take your kind of righteous
>> understandably. Why you keep saying
>> I'm I get so quick to anger just watching her talk.
>> I must be getting my period soon.
>> Okay. Uh Donnie, thank the gifted sub. Let's go. >> I'mma
pray on it. >> I uh You're going to like the Candace approach,
right? I had to speak to a pastor and they told me not to do
so. >> I am I'm going to link this video to my pastor.
I'm going to email it to him and see what he
>> uh Donnie here. Another gifted uh to maybe Wendy. Let's
go. >> Have him pray over me.
>> All right. Uh hold on. There's something >> problem
is that I >> Oh, right. She keeps calling it righteous
anger. It's like Yeah. Understandable or >> Yeah. Understandable
anger. Like um >> they're understandably angry. Yes. They
>> like Yeah, it makes sense. How do people >> righteously
angry about that? But the problem is that I think the news tries
to take your kind of righteous anger so to speak and
weaponize it for whatever
agenda that they might have. And I think when it gets weaponized
towards something that is no longer righteous or justice or towards
what like is moral, that's I think where we start slipping into
unrighteous anger. >> Yeah. What's you know, speaking of
the story with a young girl from >> I'm going to I did
not have to email my pastor. I'mma forgive her for this.
>> this got autism.
So, she's just like
hung on to the word righteous. I don't I think if you asked her
about it, she would use a different word.
>> Yeah, I think she would drop it.
>> Oh, fair enough. She's forgiven. We've forgiven her.
>> Pray. What's wrong with the blacks? >> I don't
know. Do you know the story of Stan Lee in in Canada? >> Not
that I'm aware of right now. What is >> So, there was a
man in Canada, this Asian.
She didn't just say there's nothing wrong with the blacks.
Okay, I'm
>> What's wrong with the blacks? Have you ever heard the
story of Darth Plagius the Wise? It's not a story the Jedi would
tell you.
I start I'm gonna start doing Star Wars references now for one
conservative boomers in here and then two just for Cherry to
see. >> No idea what the he was talking about and Lee in
in Canada. >> Not that I'm aware of right now. What is
>> So there was a man in Canada this Asian
>> donated $3. Her saying righteous is like when she used
to say scorched earth a lot for some reason.
Uh, that is true. That is kind of what it's like. Ruben Ruben
>> Donnie here. Thank you for the gifted sub, too. Anemone,
you're systematically off the white names in chat. I appreciate
it. Okay, keep doing God's work. Thank you very much. >> Cotic
episode and he beheaded and cannibalized another person
um in in a Greyhound bus. Uh this was I think 8 to 10 years ago
now. So, I don't know. >> I remember this. I didn't know
that guy's name was Stan Lee, but everybody in Canada remembers
the Asian guy who decapitated somebody and was like eating him
on a bus. Everyone remembers that. I believe he walked around
like he was uh like he was holding a lantern. I believe he walked
back and forth in the bus holding the head up like staring at
people outside of the bus. It's terrifying. Crocodile. No, no,
no. He was This guy was just like severely mentally ill. Like
he was just mentally >> Is this This is like Aerodite's
moment. This is her origin story. This is when I became like
an extremist Canadian.
>> I don't Well, I have no idea. But I what I don't understand
with this whole where she's going with this. >> I've seen
her hold up a
a time or two. >> Yeah, I've seen it. It's happened. But
I think I don't understand where she's going with this because
the question was what's wrong with the blacks? How is she going
to It was Vince. I was going to say Stanley. I feel like I would
remember. It was Vinceley though. Yeah.
How is this an answer to what is wrong with the blacks? And she's
like, "Have you heard of this Asian guy who went crazy and cut
a person's head off on a
That's the answer.
That's That's her working on answer. Hey, yeah, it's so tragic.
What happened to that Ukrainian girl? What's wrong with the blacks,
Kyla? And she goes, "Well, have you heard of Vincent Lee? Stabbed,
beheaded, and cannibalized while riding a Greyhound Canada bus.
Jesus Christ."
if this is racial necessarily this specific situation. Um,
but there >> Oh, why didn't you just say that there's no
reason to believe that this is >> There's an issue that
we have to talk about, which is how we handle like mental health
and crime.
>> And so, >> just say there's nothing wrong with
the blacks. Then, >> what if there what if she thinks there's
something wrong with the blacks? >> Yeah. Now, I feel like
you think there's something wrong with the blacks. >> She
didn't want to take that on. Okay. Uh, infamously,
it's very funny because I, you know, she's close to Briana Woo.
Brianna Woo took this same tack. She she put up the same strategy
once in another debate with Andrew Wilson over gun control. When
Andrew Wilson wanted to get into the urban, you know, black-on-black
crime, the the urban gun, you know, crime statistics,
Woo is like, "No, no, no. Black people don't do anything." No,
no, no. That's crazy to say it's like anything to do with black
people. And Andrew Wilson's making the classic argument like,
well, it seems like in these black communities there's a lot
more gun. It's not even a little bit. There's a lot more gun
violence, right? And she refused to like even talk about it.
Maybe Erdite's going to take the same tack here where it's like
she's just going to pretend she doesn't hear the question. Didn't
even hear. Okay. She just started talking about something else.
I also remember that one of those uh progressive victory
whatever discord meetings that I was in where it was her the
cherry bred TV person and Xanderhal
making the argument
not providing birth control for free was actually like racist.
>> it made no sense. >> and I was like yeah I'm not
>> very strange. I don't understand.
>> Very interesting. No. Yeah, >> but in America,
what's wrong with the >> Jesse knows. Jesse's going to
reframe. Okay. You thought you could get away from me? Answer
the question. >> Jesse Jesse is a ruckus. He knows exactly
what's wrong with the blacks in his own mind. So, answer it.
>> What's What's wrong with the blacks? Well, have you
heard of like a schizophrenic man in Canada who did a bus a murder
on a bus once? It's kind of the same. So, I don't know that this
is about the blacks. Cool. What's wrong with the blacks? >> You
tell me.
>> No, you're the expert. I'm asking you.
I' I've never aspoused to be the expert on black people.
>> Wait, how how how
is she involved in this space for 5 years? How is she going across
the country arguing these things? >> Never gotten hit with
1350 before in her entire life somehow. >> Or did she never
disagree with it? >> I don't
>> What the are you doing? I don't know. I'm not the expert.
You're not the expert on a lot of you talk on. >> Why wouldn't
you just say I don't know. Is there I I'm unaware of anything
wrong with the blacks specifically. Why would you say something
like that? >> The one panel we have where you told people
I'm your expert. You weren't the expert. That didn't shut you
up. So, what's your opinion here?
>> Your husband's half black.
>> Oh, wait. What? I forgot about that. That is true, isn't
it?
>> I've never supposed to be the expert on black people.
Definitely not my
>> Have you noticed? Not all, not all. Not at all, but
most blacks are very angry and violent today. >> I don't
know if I found that they're all angry and violent. I think that
they're >> Kyla, don't deny his reality, Kyla. I thought
you're trying to build a bridge here. You're trying to be understanding.
Empathize with Jesse and try to understand why he thinks all
blacks are violent and angry. I I guarantee you on a whole bunch
of other topics, she could empathize. She would do that exact
thing. But it's like sometimes there are stupid topics and this
is probably one of them or one of them you should just respond
with like what your opinion is. It's just very it's very interesting
that she's uh not taking either attack >> Not all not all
not all but most blacks are very angry and violent today. >> I
don't know if I found that they're all angry and violent. I think
that there is higher rates of it within that
>> Why is that? I >> think it's complicated, right?
I think some of it is born in righteous anger and some of it's
u been what we talked about weaponized for unrighteous causes.
>> As a white lady, do you feel concern because right now
there's a genocide on white people, white women being knocked
out, robbed on the streets. And >> let's go. Jesse Lee
Peterson knows the talking points. >> Is there a genocide
on white people? I think white women need to be on the domestic
terrorist list in the United States. It's like quite the opposite.
They're here as pure terrorists against my country.
>> That's Canadian white women though. That's a little
different. Okay. >> Ry donated $3. I will not stand for
these lies from Cherry. Eerodite would never date a black. She's
dating a Spartan warrior who doesn't do tasks lacking in masculinity,
such as breadwinning. Okay, that's way too long a donation for
me to reread for Cherry, but thank you very much. Ry basically
said a black person did it. >> Okay. Okay. >> getting
a Spartan warrior. >> Yeah, but he doesn't he's so masculine
that he's willing to take up the feminine role in the relationship.
Yeah. >> Uh because he believes that Vikings though they
were probably infamous for
I don't know pillaging
gold and that
you know what I forgot what the his cope was on that. Let me
stop pretending like >> that they that you needed to steal
it from people you couldn't trade for it. That mercantalism like
being a merchant was a feminine uh feminine behavior. Collecting
wealth was a feminine behavior and that's why he doesn't do it
>> that's why he doesn't work. Yeah. That's why he doesn't
make uh any money or earn a living.
Sounds very Andrew Tate like. >> Like if I was going to
be as good faith as possible as possible with Nick, I think it
was something like, well, you don't necessarily know that that's
a feminine behavior that I don't like work. Here's like a culture
that was that where like the masculine people didn't work. >> It
just it just sounds like you want to present yourself as masculine
by making your wife do all of the earning and all the like labor.
>> Which, hey, that that's fine. Don't bring the Vikings
into this. Andrew Tay got the same mindset.
>> And no one cares about the white people. >> Does
it concern you that there's a genocide on white people today?
>> I don't know if I would agree with that for any I've
not heard about the genocide on >> the white genocide is
terrifying. Okay. >> Does this [__] not know
anything? >> Hard to know stuff. Okay. Very difficult to
know. >> You're literally talking to like a 60 IQ
podcaster known for just being stupid. Just say no. >> Do
you remember how hard she went on chud logic over the uh the
Dr. K stuff? >> Yeah. Ivormectin.
>> No, not Ivormectton. The Ayurveda >> Ayurveda.
I was like I just asked you that and then I'm like wait it's
in your >> Yeah I do know I know her arrogance. I know
it very well when she especially when she's wrong. >> Yeah.
But not with Jesse Lee Peterson. Okay. Cuz he's one of the blacks.
>> Oh no. I think it's because a lot of people are going
to watch this.
>> Yeah. possibly.
True. Yeah. I think maybe this is a part of her strategy, too.
She doesn't want to uh >> she doesn't know if she has to
It looks like maybe the tides are going towards being a right-wing
grifter again and maybe being racist. So, she's she's keeping
all her doors open. >> Keeping all the options open. >> All
right. I think it's something like that where I think she's she's
probably if I had to guess making now I say this while she's
on a Wick panel tonight. I feel like there's something something
I've gotten from her marketing which is like I'm going to not
be quite as contentious anymore. I'm going to be like understanding
and empathetic and everything with people, right? I get that
from like her marketing, but then also she's on a Wick panel
and I can't imagine if if she's debating like bread pillars or
something, she's not going to be kind. I don't think she's capable
of being kind to those people. So, I don't exactly know where
she's going or what she's cooking with this with this whole shift,
but be interesting to see after this if she doesn't disagree
with Jesse on some stuff. It's like Jesse's saying some stuff
and she's not saying no, you're wrong, right? >> She just
literally doesn't know. Why do I have to hear from somebody who
doesn't >> Don't you Jesse Jesse about to hit her with
like, haven't she noticed that like black people are like smelly
and and low IQ and she's going to be like, I don't know about
that. >> Some of them have righteous anger, but some of
them is misplaced. >> I'm just not really sure. I'm not
an expert on the smelliness of black people. Okay. I just, you
know, Jesse, that's maybe that's like your opinion or something,
but I'm not an expert, so don't ask me. >> Do you think
there's a white genocide? Oh, I don't know. What do you What
do you mean you don't know?
You're literally you're on the side of people that is like is
reluctant to call what Israel is doing a genocide, right? Or
is she calling it a genocide?
She went to Israel, so I assume that she's not calling it a genocide.
Um,
it just it's so crazy to me. This is >> It's a little crazy.
Think of a non- negative stereotype. Hold on. I'm imitating Maximus.
You understand? I'm imitating Jesse Lee Peterson, right? Do you
think Jesse Lee Peterson knows a non- negative stereotype about
black
>> He literally doesn't. He literally >> Yeah, he
does not. >> It wouldn't work for the hypothetical. >> I
like that op, Dave. Maybe she's just here to learn from JLP.
>> I just want to I want to think like JP. You tell me
>> about a knockout and >> listen, you're a guy who's
had a stroke as one person with a brain injury to another. I
want to learn from you. Okay. Teach me. 679K subs. Let's go.
>> The rapist of white women and knocking out white men
and all that.
>> No, I haven't. >> You're not aware that that's
going on? >> I don't know if I've heard of it being called
a white genocide. Um I don't know if I have seen any evidence
of like specifically white targeting. Um, I think most violence,
for example, if it's if you're blaming like black people, I think
most violence to black people is also done by black people. >> Well,
that's happening, too. But most violence
done by whites to whites are done by blacks. >> I don't
know if that's true if I'm being honest. I haven't prepped the
stats on that, but I'd have to see if that's >> Uh, are
you I read that you are a
>> Let's go. She got one. She knows something. Let's go.
Oh my god. Yes, she is aware she's a liberal. Holy. I thought
we might go this entire interview without her
>> But
I will forever have this problem. I don't think you can actually
be I don't think you can be a Christian and be a >> Uh
maybe not. Maybe that might be there might be some conflicts
there is that like Christian morality prescribes some behaviors
that liberalism says you >> it prescribes a knowledge that
you would have to throw out in order to be a
>> Yeah, probably like you could have something that comes
close to liberalism or you could mesh with liberals as a Christian
because liberalism because it sprung out of places that were
Christian. I think there's a lot of overlap with actual Christian
morality, right? Like just in terms of don't murder, don't like
all the laws are very much like there there's a huge overlap
there. But yeah, probably like Christianity does say you're morally
wrong for not doing certain things. You're morally wrong for
engaging in certain behaviors that liberalism doesn't prescribe
against at all and are kind of antithetical to the things liberalism
does say. It's like >> to me I I see it as being a Christian
is knowing if you don't wear a seatelt
you could get seriously injured if you get in a car accident.
Whereas being a liberal is well it's your choice to wear a seat
belt and that's fine. I'm going to wear my seat belt and but
everyone is free to choose. I think if you are if you worry about
your neighbor you want them to wear a seat belt or you don't
want to pretend like there's no harm in choosing to not wear
a seat belt.
>> Yeah. But I think liberalism would broadly prescribe
a harm in wearing a seat belt. like liberalism like you still
the laws against it's the it's like the conclusion of liberalism
is complete autonomy but people left to their own devices will
result in
>> So if you are like a a
deeply serious Christian I don't think you could you could really
map yourself on to being a liberal unless you are confused on
what that means. >> Uh possibly. U hold on one second here.
Stalin sloth said 75% of the founding fathers disagree founding
fathers of liberalism would disagree with what I said. I don't
I don't see how like I I'm >> I agree dingling. I'm not
saying like there are aspects of liberal liberalism that I wouldn't
oppose. But I don't think I would be supportive of like a liberal
party. I wouldn't call myself a liberal. That would be dishonest
because
because of my faith. Does that make sense?
I think for people who have not found God, then being a liberal
makes sense. But I think if you are a Christian, it does not
make sense to call yourself both. Unless your goal is to be more
appealing to people who are not Christians.
That's what I'm saying is like a bit dishonest about it. >> Sure.
Uh I would say to me
to me the thing that seems like a contradiction
is
if you have following God and like the church as like a top priority
I don't think that work. I think then you would have some element
of that in government. A prescription against um discriminating
on faith seems totally incompatible with with a like believing
in Christian
That that's it seems to be the case to me.
But again, I'm not somebody who's like studied this stuff. So,
>> also I would not I would not generally call myself a
conservative. I would say I'm an independent. I think the conservative
movement doesn't really exist exist. It's like a Christian right
movement. I'm not a Christian right. >> Okay. All right.
We uh we continue on. I'm I we're both arguing with chat. I don't
have I don't have like super strong opinions on this. So, >> I'm
also still really like baby in my faith. So, I don't understand
how that how much that um is changing my political ideology.
I'm just as like accepting as I was before. So,
I understand why people in this chat would want to grill me
another time. You guys
>> are you I read that you are a liberal.
>> I'm sorry. >> Yes, I'm liberal. >> And how
can you What does it mean to be a liberal? What does that mean
to you?
Um, so I believe in a couple things. Strong institutions, uh,
a social safety net, and some level of valuing for kind of like
social unity under core
>> Is a social safety net a part of liberalism? I feel
like there's a decent chance it's not. Or am I crazy?
That's interesting,
right? That wouldn't be a part of liberalism at all as far as
I know. Sockdown. Yeah, different.
And how is it possible to be a Christian and a liberal? >> Very
possible. I don't think your faith uh should be underneath your
politics. I think if you think that these two things must be
kind of hierarchically organized, that's probably an issue. >> But
liberals are like they tend to be
they believe in socialism.
They they believe in free stuff, you know. Uh >> I don't
know if Jesus was opposed to free stuff. I'm not I'm not a socialist.
Not all liberals are the same, right? Like there's there's a
lot of camps in in the liberal space.
>> Oh, I see. And what type of liberal are
>> Uh I'm not the socialist type, that's for sure. Uh I'm
like a standard democracy capitalist lib. Yeah. The leftist would
say a liberal. A lib. >> So you would fe Are you a feminist?
>> Yeah. Not one that many own, but yes. >> So are
you a li a liberal feminist? Uh, am I a liberal feminist? Probably
not, cuz that's like a I don't Do you know much about like the
feminist civil war that's going on right now?
>> Not feminist civil war.
>> Uh, Erdike declared it. Okay. Erid's like, I'm a different
kind of feminist. I declare
>> Welcome to the feminist movement. Women have always
disagreed and debated
>> what their place is. Yeah, >> sure.
I know even less about feminism than I know about religion. So,
>> oh my god, I went into a room full of feminists and
they didn't all immediately agree with me and I believe I know
better than them. It's a civil war.
Congratulations. The the feminist movement got you the ability
to even be in that room and talk about that. >> Sure. Uh
I think the overlap with Lav in terms of the behaviors is very
funny.
>> Kind of. They hate >> not mocking Lav just laughing.
You know, if you pointed that out to her, I do, >> man.
And they want to take over. >> Might not like that. >> They
do. I think they're all they all agree at least that we don't
like Peterson, but um yeah, there's a lot of factions. Um some
of them have a whole island. Like Britain is like the feminist
space that doesn't like trans people. Um yeah, there's a lot
of infighting amongst feminists. So, uh liberal feminist is like
a specific label. I'm not a liberal feminist in like the feminist,
uh philosophical framework. Uh, are you a millennial or a Z?
>> I'm like the tail end of a millennial. I'm 31. >> Oh,
okay. And so,
>> hold on. Hold on. I actually I have to uh ask Stalin
to Slav. So, you could say liberalism isn't a moral framework,
but if you think if you think things are moral under Christianity,
they're like moral requirements and your freedom of religion
that is your liberal like your liberal expression of like understanding
and respecting other ideologies, other religions and stuff. If
you have freedom of religion and you have things that are voted
on in your country, laws that you totally disagree with based
on your Christian faith, based on like actual doctrine, aren't
you placing liberalism above your faith and thereby like not
following your faith? You're actually violating your moral system?
But that that's like again I don't know enough about this but
it just that's like my basic understanding of
>> I like don't know the words well enough to have those
arguments. So sometimes it could be weird. >> I feel like
this is one of those things where we should just be in the Discord
one day hanging out and talk about it before we make it like
stream content. >> Yeah. Sure. Sure. Sure. >> The
feminist
uh philosophical framework. >> Are you a millennial or
Z?
I'm like the tail end of a millennial. I'm 31. >> Oh, okay.
And so, how does your parents feel about you being a Christian
and a >> They're okay with it. >> They're they're
conservative, but they um I I think in Canada especially, our
politics are very
um our faith is first and our politics are second. So, um, we
disagree on certain things, especially like politically, but
it doesn't change like the unifying front that we like believe
in the same God and the same faith and that we, um, worship the
same God. So, >> Oh, I see. And they know that you're a
feminist liberal, >> they do. Yeah. >> And do they
complain about that or they accept it? >> No, it's more
like uh teasing and jokes. In Canada, politics is very different
in Canada than America. Uh politics is like in America it's like
your tribe.
Um
uh politics in Canada we have like seven parties federally. So
>> it's pretty normal to vote like municipally you vote
NDP
and proincially you might vote conservative and federally you
might vote like liberal. So we're just a lot less like die hard
on our >> Wait,
maybe that's the case. Do
>> hold on. I was just like m in municipal elections do
you have people who are part of parties like are they openly
running as a part of a party I feel like I've not always seen
that but I also don't want to say anything more so uh but provincial
federal sure >> parties and I think that really changes
the way that we experience
politics compared to like Americans where seems like politics
is very identity tied for
>> and how did you get so involved
>> uh but also in Canada like a federal federal level,
they're really only two parties. There's been like a minor blip
where a third party has kind of affected things. There've been
like here or there they've been able to push people in a direction,
but it's realistically two parties. It's basically red versus
blue here as well, except they're flipped. Reds are liberals,
blues are conservatives in politics. And why?
>> That's a good question. Um, I think I've just always
been very interested in learning. Um, I love philosophy and Aristotle
is my favorite philosopher and so he has this rule that politics
is like one of the greatest forms of philosophizing. So I think
I I very naturally moved into politics because of my interest
in philosophy. Um, yeah.
>> Would you ever run for office
>> in America? I can't. So >> I can't in America,
right? Would
you ever be interested in doing something like that? Even though
you can't do it in Canada, in America? >> Probably not.
>> She's just trying to infiltrate my >> You have
kids?
>> Uh, no. >> Oh, okay. Um,
I noticed that ever since women been allowed to vote
that everything just been screwed up and it's getting worse.
Was it a mistake to allow women the rights to vote?
>> No, I think it's like the morally correct position.
I think it is part of the American project. Um, agency is really
really important both in our faith. Um, choice is salvation and
in the American project. So, no, giving women the choice uh is
good.
>> So, was it a good thing or a bad thing to allow them
to vote though? It's good. It's moral. >> I'm sorry. >> It's
the good thing. It's the moral thing to do. >> But why
is this the moral thing? And when they were not or a good thing,
when they were not allowed to vote, America was amazing.
But once they allowed them to vote, they want free health care.
They want free babysitting
services. They want us to pay for all that. They want um to save
the blacks. And they >> emotional women just wanted black
people not to be slaves. They broke everything for us, Kyla.
Don't you see it? Says the 70-year-old black man. >> They
want to save the blacks. I want her to speak up and say no, not
all women want to save the blacks. >> Or it's just like,
why is that bad? Anything? I don't know. She's just listening.
Okay, she's listening and
>> They care. They want us to pay for everything and they
always vote the wrong way because of their emotional and
capability.
They tend to be like unable to make the right decision because
their their psychic is not logical.
>> Like women are women are just actually children. Right.
this I'm sorry my my anger does come up watching like this because
she will decide who's worth talking to who's not worth talking
to. This is a mentally stable. There's valuable things coming
out of his mouth. This is an audience she would like to capture.
This is a person that's serious to her. This is a this is worth
her time. But there are other people in the space, maybe I'm
talking about myself, maybe who have put out a very thoughtful
uh
series of videos just pointing laying out my issues. Not worth
her time. That's unserious. That's this I'm like a a person who's
unwell, who should not be engaged with, but Jesse Lee Peterson.
>> Well, yeah.
>> Yeah, exactly. Peterson 700,000 subs. It's just right.
700,000 subs of people who hate
and who want to do all of the hating that he's doing >> and
that she won't even explicitly say the hatred is like wrong.
>> Or maybe she does eventually, but right now she's going,
I don't know about >> Now it's like, okay, women are too
emotionally immature. Women cannot help this country. This country
was way better when women couldn't vote. >> And I'm waiting
for her to go like, no, you're wrong. >> Tell me you're
doing anything but on here to be a pick me.
>> You're just naive. You want to play the bimbo role of
I don't really know what's going I'd have to look at the numbers.
>> I feel like
I feel like almost certainly she can't do this the whole time.
>> I in my head I'm like she kind of wants to be taken
seriously. She knows she has to like disagree on points here.
Right.
>> Now I don't know how you go in Jesse Peterson's show
and aren't ready to argue that blacks aren't subhuman cuz he
kind of makes those arguments basically every show. Like black
people are savage. Black people want to do >> He didn't
even say that. He said, "What's wrong with the blacks?"
>> Well, he's going to go further. He eventually went into
like they're violent and angry, right?
>> But he he does that. He does do like anti-black talking
points all the time. >> And she had nothing. She's like,
"Well, some of it's righteous anger. Some of it is just misplaced."
>> That was her response. Yes. Uh, so I don't know. She
wasn't ready for that. Now, Jesse's second most popular stuff
to me is women suck. Okay.
Women's suffrage. That sucked. How? There's no way she has she
could be
to defend that to defend women. That's like her thing. This is
basically a dumber version of the whatever podcast. Erdite, are
you not ready to defend women here?
She's got to be. Okay. She's got to be. I think I think she's
going to come back and talk about it. It'd be incredibly embarrassing
for her if she doesn't.
>> I'm just I'm just laying out what I think has to happen
here. She can't keep going like, "Well, I don't know about that.
Why?" She has to take some stand at some point. Well, the stand
is clearly not about the issues. It's about who's got a platform
that's big enough for me to
network through.
>> I I feel like that has to become transparent or she
must realize that becomes trend. But maybe not. Maybe she's not
willing to look forward cuz I understand I agree with you that
that's the uh that's the motivation cuz we've seen it play out
in a lot of other places. I don't understand how she spends so
much time reading her haters and hasn't gotten any of the criticism
to like sink in. like she she just thinks the criticism is not
correct. It's like, "Hey, it seems like you make all your decisions
based on clout." How does that not sink in at some point? >> Well,
you don't understand. It's like Connor, like I need to grift.
I need to clout chase in order to take care of my family and
and then I'll be able to do like really good stuff in the world.
>> I got to make this money right now.
>> They tend to be like unable to make the right decision
because their their psych is not logical.
And as a result, the country going to hell in a hand basket.
Do you agree with
>> No. Do you think that America in 1880 is bigger, stronger,
and more American than America in like the 1980s?
>> I think America were better before women had the right
to vote than it is. >> So 1880 America was better. Even
though Britain was a superpower, >> it still were better
than it is today. Because now that if you notice now that the
women are allowed to vote and there's according to reports more
women than men socialism is coming about
men jobs are being taken away from them.
So that's an interesting date to choose because the 19th amendment
was ratified in 1920 after World War I. And I would say that's
probably right there is the point right when it gets when it
gets ratified. Was America on its best track then? Yeah, that's
after World War I. like America has its whole like industrial
complex like set up. That is
that is a part of like the height of American power. >> It's
not quite there yet cuz they haven't collected all of their wealth
yet from helping rebuild Europe, but like it's it's getting there.
It's right
>> But she went she goes 1880s, right, instead of 1920.
>> So I that's very interesting to me. Okay. And I would
say that probably women's suffrage, I'm guessing that there would
be a lot of people opposed to women's suffrage through the 1920s,
1930s. Like women would be opposed. I'm guessing there are a
sizable percentage of women who don't vote based on principle
through like the 1940s
who just say I shouldn't be making these >> A lot of them
rejected the the independence
um that was being like pushed for >> by by some women.
Yeah. >> Yeah. It was just interesting that she went to
like the 1880s for it cuz that's like a much easier argument
to make about like oh well the US wasn't at the top of the world
but it's like okay but just go to when women suffrage actually
came in 1920
>> and now is that a mistake? >> I I don't think
so. >> Or is she just like the world's worst feminists?
Like what's going on? >> I I think she's just doing it
because it's way easier. >> I think she go by hundreds.
>> Because she said 1980 or 1880.
Just
them by hundreds. Okay, possibly. Yeah, >> men children
are being taken away from them because of course on the side
of the woman and everything is insane
because even cars are are soft and they don't make noise anymore
cuz the women complain about the noise. They they >> it's
probably more old people, but my suspicion it's usually old people
that make noise complaints or people with young children uh versus
women. Um >> no, it's a woman's thing. Men loves loud
Why uh why did God give us the right to choose? Why does he make
salvation a
>> what I is she is she's kind of maybe she's just trying
to debate Rome into agreeing like if God gave women the choice
to the the ability to choose not to sin, to live a life without
sin, why wouldn't we give women the ability to choose to vote
or something? >> I don't think God gave the choice to not
sin. I think the way that Jesus Jesus like uh depicts it is you
have no idea the ways and the numerous ways in which you sin.
You you have no idea.
>> Like you sin more than you could possibly imagine.
It's not a choice. This world is fallen. You can't help it. God
didn't even understand it until he sent his son down. So I don't
know what she's cooking here. >> I don't Yeah, I don't
know what >> he gave me the right to choose. >> He
did. He put He put the tree of evil. He made choice right from
Adam and Eve, >> right? But that was
>> wait. Okay.
>> She's talking about Adam and Eve. >> I'm not a
theological scholar, but isn't Adam and Eve like a like a like
a layup for Jesse Lee Peterson?
Isn't that like literally proving I maybe I don't understand
the choice she's making here, but like isn't that the worst story
to choose where like the woman's right to choose humanity damn
humanity to >> I also wouldn't call that a choice.
He said, "Don't do this." That was defiance. There was no choice
involved. >> Wait, did she just say the tree of evil, too?
Oh, boy.
It's the tree of knowledge, right? >> The tree of the knowledge
of good and evil. There's no choice. >> God didn't give
you the right to choose. >> He did. He put He put the tree
of evil. He made choice right from Adam and Eve, >> right?
But that was only because he wanted man to know that he's not
going to force you to love him. you have to love him or not love
him. But what does that have to do with women voting? >> Well,
if God views choice
as more important than sin, right? Because if he hadn't put the
tree of good and evil in the garden, that he we wouldn't have
ever had a choice to do sin. And so if God valued our ability
to choose even though he knew we would choose wrong,
who are we in the American project to say, "Okay, well, we we
know better and actually we're going to take away people's right
to choose cuz we're actually better than God in this way." It
seems it seems very directional with salvation. That agency
agency is like the most important thing because if you don't
have choice, then it means that you are simply a slave to doing
good things by necessity. And that isn't a good world at all.
The person who can look at evil and look at good and choose >> We
in the American broadcast. >> Anyways, that's noble. >> It's
not a we thing. And we need to make like God makes a space for
us to do that despite the fact that even with God, we choose
wrong every single day. >> But God only gave us one choice.
And that choice is to come out of hell if you want. You can live
in your misery all of your life or you can realize, you know what,
I'm tired of living in hell. And emotional people are living
in hell, right? And so you decide, you know what, God, I'm tired
of living this way. >> Help me out of it. That's the only
choice you have. Or he'll just leave you in your hell. You have
no other choice.
>> Well, I feel like even once you choose God, like Christians
still do sin,
>> But they don't choose God. But what does that have to
do with women voting? That doesn't make sense. >> Well,
it's about choice, right? The reason why I think women voting
is good is because it's giving them more choice. >> But
women don't make choices. They don't know they don't know how
to make the right choice because they're so
>> So women can't sin. >> They are so emotional
and neological, they can't make the right choice. Have you noticed
that? But >> I guess I'm asking, >> you can't tell
me that's I am I am that white woman on the plane saying that
is not real. You can't tell me that she is a real
>> because of the nonsequator question. Like the total
>> everything that she has said so far, you cannot convince
me that that is a real person. She is just a troll. She is a
paid agitator in this space. I won't be believing anything the
files. >> Uh I mean yeah I it seems pretty obvious that
a lot of people in this space do operate purely on on baiting
rage, right? In a calculated way. >> Yes. to build their
content. So, >> I will not be taking anything that you
say about Christianity seriously. Enjoy having conversations
with Jesse Lee >> I just find it really funny that Jesse
is like, "Women are too emotional to make the correct decision."
And everybody's like, "Wait, so women can't sin? I don't Is the
implication of that that the sinning is the correct decision?
I don't even know. I don't know how that's a relevant question.
I don't Yeah, I'm >> The implication is that I'm not going
to disagree with you. Women's votes are probably wrong, but don't
they have the right to vote wrong? The implication is she is
the 911 9/11 of feminism or whatever the Rihanna Wasa >> 911
of feminism. >> All of those women are >> and the
the You know what? I'm not going to go. It's okay. Press play.
>> If women can't choose, then they can't sin. They're
just kind of like >> I don't know what that had to do with
that. That >> Well, sin is about choice, right? Like if
I if I steal cookies and my parents go, "Kyla, did you steal
cookies?" And I >> "No, I've made a choice to lie to my
parents in that moment, right?"
>> The only choice that human being has is to whether they
want to come out of their misery. If you realize, you know what,
I don't like living this way. I'm unhappy or miserable or have
fear and all that. I want out. That's the only choice you make.
You never make a choice in your whole life after that. And about
agency, but shouldn't she be arguing that women aren't like inferior?
Like, I get it. She's trying to do a gotcha on Jesse with Christianity,
right? Somebody's saying it's about agency. It's really not.
It's Jesse is saying women are incapable of making good decisions.
And Kyla's going, "Yeah, but shouldn't we let them [__]
everything up?"
Isn't that Christian? Isn't that >> You're not making a
choice before that. So, is God making you sin when you are a
Christian who acts in sin? Christians sin, right? >> What
does that have to do with women? >> This is this is why
I don't like when these people talk about this because until
I went to a church myself, if I had to go off of the [__]
that I see these people talk about, yeah, I think Christianity
is awful. I think all faith is just
controlling manipul.
>> Dude, we should go. >> I think it's intentional.
>> We should go listen to when Sedon had to come on. I've
never seen Sedan angry except the one time he was like listening
to Kyla talk about her Christianity like like Christianity and
Son was like S was like vibrating in the chat. He was like freaking
the out hearing her say things. >> It is a bastardization.
And I think right now she's talking about agency when she probably
means free will, which would uh like ultimately just disregard
this as an argument when it comes to women voting.
Like you're you're not saying anything. >> Well, Jesse's
argument against women voting isn't that they can't vote or that
they don't have the ability to choose to vote. He's arguing that
they make bad decisions and they're everything up for everybody.
Free will doesn't is he's literally acknowledging that they have
the free will to vote.
>> He's he's just saying they suck at it. They make really
bad choices. And Kyla is not going, "No, come on, man. Isn't
it a Christian thing to let them everything up for everyone?"
It's like, >> She's not disagreeing with him. I have yet
to see her disagree with him. I've seen her ask him for for data.
Oh, I would need to see the data.
>> Not disagreeing with him. >> Wait, blacks blacks
commit a lot of crime. I need to see the data on that >> choice,
right? Like God, you said God only allows you to have one choice.
And it's like, well, no, God, even when you make when you choose
him, he actually asks you to choose him every single day. Bear
your cross every day, right? And so, God allows us allows us
to choose constantly. He's constantly allowing us the space to
choose to sin or not to sin, even as Christians, >> every
single day. That's that's why we need him every day. We don't
need God once in our life. We need God every single day because
we have the choice to do noble or ignoble. Um, and if God's
choice to that level, we probably should, too. >> So,
so I guess you're not going to answer the question about what
is that since women are so illogical
>> So, Jesse Lee Peterson is the master of the tactic.
Okay. I'm going to let you yap and then I'm going to ask you
the same question that you're
>> So, I'm saying women are fundamentally, Kyla. I'm saying
women are
and you're telling me they have the right to be. I don't disagree,
but but everything's been worse since they gained the at least
legal right in America to be >> and influence the political
system.
Will she answer the question this time? >> And mentally,
they can't make the right decision.
Why would they have a be given the right to vote when they don't
know what they want?
>> I I guess I'm saying to you, I think women can make
choices. I think women can sin. Um I think women make choices
all the time. You might not agree with
>> You think I think women can sin. >> Everybody
sins. >> I think women have like agency. I think you know
I think I decided to come here and that might not have been a
good decision but I I made that decision. I I think you know
you know >> the choices that they make. But for us to call
their actions wrong, we either have to say well they're just
meat robots that can't help but doing evil things. We have to
say women are choosing bad things, but if they're meat robots,
then they're more like children. We don't get mad at children
for like doing the wrong. >> Yeah, that's that's literally
that if you watch one JLP episode or you like actually have talked
to him here. Yeah. He's basically arguing they're children. They
they don't make good decisions. He's not arguing that you should
hate them for he's saying they shouldn't have the right to do
that in in the system, the political system >> thing when
they don't know better. We like teach them better. But I just
I don't view women that way. I think women are adults that can
make choices. They can make bad choices and good choices. I just
believe in a system where we allow them to make those choices,
including allowing them to make bad choices because I think that's
what's modeled for us in our faith. >> Do you agree with
me that the God above is the man's God and the God below, Satan
is?
>> Jesse. Jesse, you know what? You're struggling here.
Let me save you with a totally insane comment. Please don't get
this wrong. Please don't get this wrong. >> I'd have to
look that up. I'm not sure about that. Hold on. Wait. What are
the stats on on which God represents which person? The God below.
Is that like Krishna or >> is the woman's God?
>> No, I think God made all of us in his >> That's
not what I asked though. I know he made all of us, but do you
agree? Did the woman come from God or from the man? >> Uh,
she came from his rib, but I don't think Adam made her. Right.
Eve, Eve was made by God and he put his breath into >> But
did she come from the man or did she come from God? >> Genuinely,
I think God created humanity. >> that's not what I'm asking
though. But did the woman come from the man or from
>> She came from God. >> No. Did the man come from
>> What are you scared of or the woman?
>> What are What are you scared of?
>> No. She's She's terrified. If I answer this honestly,
then I'm going to lose it. It will lead to it being the devil
is the answer. No, he took a rib from Adam and made woman. She's
not made in his image. He's made literally from him.
The same thing he created, he took that and created her. That's
still his creation. You can answer this. Just say God. Just say
Adam's rib. >> I don't even I don't even know.
>> She's insecure in her faith because it's a grift. It's
not like a real thing. I'm >> trapped. Okay. Jesse Peterson
>> is putting the aura onto her. Okay. He's he's extending
out his aura where like he's he's
already knows that she's like not really answered any questions
like substantially yet. So Jesse Lee Peterson's Yeah. He's putting
out his uh
>> is commandering. Okay. He's putting out his own and
he is >> And the thing is if you just answer it, he probably
is a little bit more insecure. But you keep saying the same thing.
So now he's probably more confident. I'm going to get this woman.
>> I'm sorry. >> Man comes from God, too. >> And
the woman came from who? >> Wait, God. God, too. Like,
she's actually giving away that she knows she has to say it.
Like, it's both.
You could just say it's both, right? I don't know why. I feel
like that would be an answer. It's both, but
>> she came from his rib. She Adam didn't make Eve. Like
I don't think men I'm not men are not God. >> But did God
take the woman out of the man and created her?
>> God did. Yeah. >> And so she's created his image.
>> In God's image. Yeah. >> No, the man's image.
>> Well, we have breast >> which is in the image
of God.
>> I Yeah. >> He's Yes. Adam's made in God's image
and then he takes from Adam's rib to make a partner that
that will be perfect for him the same as in God's image. Like
this isn't difficult. Um but I understand she feels
at least for me this is a sign that she's not here to agree with
JLP. She just the ways in which it sounds like she's agreeing
with him that maybe she's just bad. Jay- Sock walked away to
go pee.
Only Kyla can lose a debate with JLP.
I don't even understand what's happening here. She's bad. What
do you want me to say? Yeah. Um, she's literally not smart enough
to navigate. Well, her name is not so aerodite. So, maybe she's
intentionally not being smart enough. And you know what the result
is?
All of us lose. >> I'm back. Hello.
>> You know how you know how we America? by
putting bimbos all across social media on behalf of the Democratic
Party.
>> I what I Okay, what I don't understand here is if she's
not going to stand on
>> where in the world is she going to get like the audience
from? How is she going to gain the followers that she's looking
to gain if she doesn't make like any actual
if she doesn't take any position? If she's not like doing anything,
I don't I don't know. like she has to say something, right? She's
not saying anything. And I I'm sitting here like she has to take
a position or give people some reason to follow her or what is
the point of going on Jesse Peterson's?
I don't get it.
>> Literally not made. >> The man is created in God's
image and the woman is created in man in the man image. Am I
right?
>> Well, I feel like men and women are really different,
right? >> They are. But >> so if we were made in
man's image
then >> oh man was made in God's image. So wait doesn't
that
like she's totally spitball. She's like she doesn't have like
an actual answer here of what she thinks. I would just I don't
know how I would answer this but like if you don't know why didn't
you just say >> the same thing you did with everything
else. You weren't sure what's wrong with black people. You weren't
sure about all the other [__] So don't have the certainty
here if you are you know >> I don't know. He did a bad
job of making us look like men. We're pretty different. I feel
like we are made by God and God made us different. >> You
may feel that way, but >> I got a that's also where she
wrong. I got a brother and sometimes it makes me look in the
mirror like kind of look like your brother.
There's not very much that you you can listen just have a brother
and you will see how similar you look. All right.
>> I look at my brother and think you kind of look like
a woman.
I kind of look like a man sometimes if I had a beard for sure.
>> I just don't think like this question seems so not consequential.
I don't know why she can't just go like I don't really I don't
know. It doesn't really matter because she's she's arguing before.
No, no, no. We're made by God because we're made in his image.
And now she's going like if we're made in if we're made the same
as him, we're made like God made us really different, right?
We're both made in God's image. God made us really different.
I just I feel like she was trying to use the similarity before
and now she's trying to use the difference. It just seems weird
to me >> cuz I really don't look like a man. You're protesting
way too much. >> But like I don't know >> now. You
kind of look like a man to me. I'm seeing it. >> Okay.
Oh, I thought you were talking to me for a second. You're like
making eye contact. So confused. I was like
>> very confused. But I don't um I just don't know. It's
so not unconsequential.
Not unconsequential. Inconsequential. I don't understand why
she doesn't just say like, "Oh, whatever. Move on." It's weird
to get like bogged down not wanting to answer anything specifically.
Do woman come from man or does she come from God?
>> In I don't know what to tell you. I don't think that
human beings even man uh is creating
uh life in the way that God is. God breathed >> God gave
the life to the woman. God took the woman from the man's body
and created her. But he created the woman in the man's image
and created God in his >> Then why do they look so different?
>> They don't. She's made >> men and women are very
different. >> If you look, women are created like
>> I'm sorry, but when sis men decide that they're trans
and so they put on like lipstick for the first time. There are
a lot of women who look like that. I know they will go through
a lot of surgery surgeries to like feminize themselves more,
but there are a lot of um men early on in transitioning without
taking anything looking like cis women.
>> Yeah, sure. Some feminine men out there. I agree with
you. >> Women don't look like the models that you see in
magazines or on Instagram. >> Like men, they have breast
like a man. They just made to have babies. So they get milk.
All those kind of things that men don't get. But the woman >> God's
image has nothing to do with appearance. Could be. Could be.
>> It's created in the man's image and he he is
>> okay. The guy thinks pre HRT Finster is prettier than
Kyla. I don't really think you're saying much there. Okay. >> God
image. So is Satan was Have you know did you know that the woman
God is the God from below and the man's God is a u
god from above.
>> Dude's guy is a >> she I'm sorry. I've got pause
on that.
>> Dear absolute deer in the headlights look right there.
Holy sh
she's just like totally struck. Sure, it's related. Yeah, sure.
Possibly, Wendy. I don't I super don't care. I'm just laughing
that like this this question seems like Jesse's a pastor. Like
I maybe let him cook in his argument. Just go like I don't know.
Tell me about it. >> God from above.
>> I don't think that that's uh a Christian belief. No.
>> And why not? >> I would I would say that that's
>> It's taught in the Bible. Why is not a Christian belief?
uh because women and men are both made by God. God calls both
women and men to act in his image and both of them can achieve
salvation by by faith in him. This is obvious by women being
um Deborah women being used by God multiple times. Deborah the
priestess like there's multiple instances
>> was was led by men. She didn't make her own decision
that men instructed her on the decisions to make. But let me
ask this about >> that's not true >> about the woman
being uh >> oh my god she disagreed.
Will she get an extra will she extracted concession from JLP
on this >> about the woman God? Remember in the >> in
the word
where once upon a time, Adam had a relationship with God
and then his wife Eve loved him and had a relationship with him
and all three were one because the woman believed in the husband
who believed in the father. You know about that, right? >> It
sounds like when you read the Bible, God was engaging with both
of them. When they were found in sin, both were ashamed of their
nudity. It seems like God had a relationship with both of these
individuals.
>> I don't think God is a kid. And I'm calling him a kid
because he's >> [__] Sorry, I started something
else. I got to link a tweet, you know. I'll I'll pull the tweet
up in just a second as well. But
is she What is she looking at right now? Where are her eyes going
while she's like answering? >> It seems like God had a
relationship.
>> I'm sorry, but where are her eyes going? >> Both
of these individuals.
>> I don't think God only engaged with Adam. Yeah, but
it was through the husband that he had to >> I watched
I watched Dean Withers make this same move against Nick Fuentes,
>> Relationship with the wife.
>> I don't think that there's biblical >> the husband
Adam and the father were one. And when they married, the woman
became one with the husband was one with God. And then one day
the woman had to go shopping
and she went to the market and she ran up on Satan.
And Satan had always tried to tempt Adam and Adam said, "No,
get out of here. Not going to listen to the >> I don't
think there's any >> get out of here, Satan. >> Said
Adam first say uh the woman went to the market and she met Satan
there. And Satan was like, "Hey, Eve, how are you?" She like,
"Fine."
And he asked her, "You still with that man?"
And she like, "Yeah, I am. I love my husband."
And he like, "You could be your own woman. You know how I listen
to that man. She like, "No." Long story short, she went home,
made dinner. They were having dinner. She and Adam and she like,
"I saw Satan today at the market." And Adam like, "Stay away
from him. He's trying to deceive you. Don't believe the lie."
And she's like, "Okay." And then she went back a second time,
another time, and she ran into Satan again. And Satan said to
her, "Adam, you still with that woman? I mean, Eve, you still
with that man?" like, "Yeah, don't listen to >> Is this
all in like the Mormon book? I don't think I've read this in
the Bible. Maybe it's in the Mormon Bible. >> He listened
to his father. He's not even his own man. You can be your own
woman. You can take your bra off. You can do what you want. >> This
is from the book of Jesse. Okay, this is a unique This is him
cooking something up uniquely. I have no [__] idea
what he's talking about right now.
>> And she believed that lie. And the moment she believed
that lie, she no longer believed her husband. They became separated
and Satan became her gods
and then Adam couldn't believe he's like what have you done Satan
you listen I mean Eve you listen to the devil now you can't believe
the truth you don't obey me anymore anything
and then Eve became very puffed up because now she know she know
about evil and good so she finally convinced Adam
you don't have to listen to your father you could be like me
you You can know good and evil. >> I know Tequila Sunset.
That's the tweet I pulled up. >> You can judge. You can
>> Let Jesse finish his story. Okay. Jesse is speaking.
Don't cut him off while he is doing his whole madeup story about
Eve meeting Satan at a flea market. >> God and everything.
And Adam listened to the woman and then the woman became his
God because he could no longer believe the father. And father
like, "What have you done, Adam?" He's like, "Well, you gave
me that woman. you may I listen to that woman. And he said, "Well,
because you listen to the woman, you're going to suffer." And
so every time the man listen to his woman today, he suffers.
And then >> damn,
let's go. The evil that come through to the children come through
the woman because her nature until she's truly born again of
God. Her nature is evil because she has no love and it's passed
on to the children generation after generation after generation.
Have you noticed that as a Christian?
Maybe there's a new version of the message that I haven't read,
but I don't remember that. Readis, if I'm being dude, his response,
read Genesis. Okay, I'm again not a biblical scholar. I have
seen a lot of recreations of the original story of the original
like Genesis story. Never seen this part. Okay, this is like
some anti-female suffrage retelling of the Garden of Eden that
I've never been aware of. Okay. >> With you. >> Yeah.
You I understand that. Read Genesis. It's in the fall of Adam
and Eve. And don't remember anything. You will see where >> you
will see where Satan is the woman's god and the god above. Well,
until that man overcome the woman, >> the woman is his
god. That's why men don't know what to do with women because
they got to overcome mama, forgive their mother so they can come
back to the father. So that's why read that. So you see since
you're a Christian, you would see why Satan is the woman's god
and evil come through the woman. >> I think if any notable
actual religious leader had come to that conclusion, I might
be open to you. I don't think anyone theologically agrees with
you, but again, maybe I haven't read the New Version. I don't
know if this is like the Mormon Bible or the message or >> It's
not the New
King James Bible. >> It's not Genesis, right? >> What
What is >> Well, you literally you said it was >> notable.
What' you say? Notable what?
>> What's a notable theologian?
>> Uh, somebody that's respected typically in the field
and study of like theology. They've probably got like a PhD in
theology. They've probably gone to seminary. Um, the Catholics
have a system by which they kind of develop a
um kind of like seminary system. Protestants have their own system,
but kind of somebody who rises through the ranks in their >> Those
people don't those people wouldn't know God if you had lunch
with them. They're intellectually
separated from God and an intellectual person cannot. >> We
love Jesse. Okay. He's just like, you know, no, I am a respected
theologian. Respected theologians wouldn't know God if he sat
down with him for lunch. Okay. I'm I'm a I'm an on the street.
I'm an what is it in the Frey preacher? Okay. He's out there.
He's talking to people. He knows everything. >> I know
God. They can know about him. They can read about him and talk
about him, but they can't know him. >> So pastors don't
know God.
>> have you noticed that?
>> I disagree. So
>> Uh I think there's a lot of really godly people in this
world. I think there's a lot of good thinkers that God tries
to speak through and really um Yeah. >> Were women created
to lead or to follow?
>> Um I think originally to be like uh kind of like a support
character in the relationship. I think that that's like shifted
over time though. So, were they created to lead or to follow?
>> I think I said they were probably created originally
to become >> the answer. Why do people get so
so mad about like actually
just answer the question? You could say follow. They were originally
made. They they followed. They were followers. That was like
the original thing. You just said original they were support
role. Like she said that you're saying the same thing, right?
I don't know. >> I think he said complimentary to Adam,
right? Adam can't bear children. Um, men tend to be a little
bit more aggressive, a little bit less good at building relationships
and community. So, I think Eve was built to complement all of
the weaknesses that man has.
>> And so, were women created to lead or to >> Wait,
soapbox, wouldn't this be like just doing whatever God told them?
Wasn't that the point? You're supposed to I thought that was
the point. Wouldn't that mean Okay, maybe I'm >> I'm sorry.
Neither. >> Neither. And is it uh >> Well, I guess
follow. Well, follow in the same way that I think Adam was built
to follow. >> Oh, okay. I Okay, >> I suppose >> follow
who?
>> And a woman is supposed to follow the
>> God. If if a woman is putting man over
>> that's a problem. God has to come first for every single
person. But a woman that has put God first will naturally obey
and follow her husband without any
>> I think there's a lot of good reasons for why women
engage in submission with their husbands. Yeah. >> Um speaking
of women leaders, have you noticed that ever since they put women
in leadership role in our government in churches
even in the home when the father is not there to guide her how
to raise the children? Have you noticed that everything get worse
because the man is the light of the family? If he's not there,
the the woman can't find her way in raising children or anything.
Have you noticed in America and around the world when they allow
women to be in a leadership role, things only get
um I haven't found that to be consistently true, but I think
in general women are not uh taught and reared in general to be
uh like efficient in leadership. I think in general we teach
boys how to lead in a way that we often don't teach young girls
to lead. So in many ways I think women can be weaker leaders
but there are still like good female leaders >> but women
men are not taught to be leaders. It's natural. is in the DNA.
It
>> dude, this guy's this guy is absolutely dominating the
debate. Okay, I don't know where they're going, but he's absolutely
dominating. I'm going to pull up the Z tweet right now because
I need to break the I need to break the tension with this guy
a little bit. I'm I'm like just listening. I'm starting to like
fall asleep a little bit. He's starting to get me in a trance.
Okay, I need to break the Jesse Lee Peterson spell really quick.
Let's check this out. Okay, Z tweets something. I got no idea
what she's tweeting about. I only give private jet Holly hand
two weeks before at TPUSA gets rid of him. He sucks at debates.
His name is weird and he's out of touch. This man is no Charlie
Kirk.
Oh, we are on our way now. So, is this guy This guy's going to
do some Charlie Kirk replacement stuff? I guess maybe.
Conspiracy lemur asks insensitive. You say this is him throwing
back Z's old tweet. I don't think Tyler Robinson Charlie Kirk.
The FBI is lying to everyone. and she responds,"I stand by this.
This was 20 minutes ago. 21 minutes ago, 22 minutes ago." She
stands by that Tyler Robinson didn't kill Charlie Kirk. Now,
there's a lot of videos. This actually ties into the last piece
of content we're going to do tonight, or the next piece of content
we're going to do tonight, I should say. All right. And if you
guys want to make sure we get to that content, there's a couple
ways you can make sure that happens. You can sub on kick. You
can give subs on kick. You can gift kicks. You can you can send
kicks. Okay? You can donate through TTS or sorry, donate through
Streamlabs or Kickbot exclamation point. Donate in the chat will
give you the TTS options. All right.
Kickbot, Streamlabs, any way you go. Okay, we are $5 away from
another two hours on stream. One sub, but for one sub, we would
have two more hours on the stream. I don't know if I used that
right. I don't think I did. But we would have two more hours
in the stream if we get another sub in. So, let's get that sub
in now. Donate, donate, donate. Get more hours on the stream.
Let's go. 500 kicks. That's all we needed right there. 500 kicks
and we're ready to go. We got two more hours in the streams.
Thank you very much, Kerski. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Two hours 54 minutes 26 seconds. Boom. Boom. Boom.
And let me reset stuff. Thank you very much. Let's continue on
with the stream. >> I think women can be weaker leaders,
but there are still like good female >> but women men are
not taught to be leader. It's natural. It's in the the DNA. It
come naturally. You have to teach a woman how to be a leader,
but because she wasn't created to be a leader, it doesn't work.
She tried to make herself be something she can't be. Have you
noticed that? >> So, you think that like Joe Biden was
a good leader? >> As a man? Joe Biden. >> Joe Biden.
>> Joe Biden didn't even know he was >> Well, he's
a man if there if >> Well, he a lot he didn't have the
right mindset. So, that's different. >> Oh, okay. So >> wouldn't
the wouldn't the question here be do you think Joe Biden would
have been a better was he a better president than Kamala Harris
would have been even though he didn't know he was president would
he have been better than Kamala Harris and Jesse Lee Peterson
definitely going to say yes to that >> uh we should just
pick Obama then >> how about the great white hope
>> I I don't know what that is >> that's that is
Obama isn't it or is the great white hope Trump I can't remember
if he says that as a denigration of Obama or if he says it's
Trump
>> okay okay >> you don't know the great white hope
>> how do neither You know this. >> I don't know
how you go on this show. You don't know that Jesse Lee Peterson
loves Trump and he calls him the great white hope. >> Well,
I know he loves Trump. I just didn't remember that he called
him the great white hope. >> They call him king. >> Are
we talking about Trump? All I'm guessing is we're talking about
Trump. >> They say, "What matter of man is this?" The wind
obeys him. They call him daddy.
Would you say he's a >> What are you saying, Jesse? What
are you, Jesse?
Why does he always drop the just every there's just little breadcrumbs
of him being gay in like every episode? >> And I call him
the great white hope. >> Donald Trump, would you say he's
a good
no. I think like >> No. Yeah, I'll say no. I'll end at
no. >> And why? No. I think the fact that basically none
of his staff from his first term wanted to come back and work
with him indicates that his his staff distrusted him, disliked
him, didn't respect him. There's something going on that made
none of them willing to come back. So >> that's your first
point. That's the only thing that she >> he's not a good
leader. People don't like him. >> She's on an un America
tour.
>> Yeah, but they they did it. anti-Trump tour and the
her banger coming out swinging is a is a foul ball. Oh, none
of his staff wants to work with him. >> I'm tired of all
this hatred for the UN America tour. Okay, their mission was
to dislodge Charlie Kirk as a major figure in American politics
and they knocked it out of the park in the first event. Okay,
Charlie Kirk ain't doing [__] anymore. They already
on America. They don't know [__] about Trump. Charlie
Kirk was their nemesis. I'm meing obviously. Parite is bringing
me to like levels of anger. She's even making she's making you
and the chat say stuff that is like bringing me to levels of
anger. She is my 9/11.
>> That's that's rough. Okay. >> Liked him. Didn't
respect him. There's something going on that made none of them
willing to come back. >> So Donald Trump is there now
and been there for a minute. Do you think he's a good leader?
>> And why not? I think that he's leading the country towards
greater levels of disunityity. Um, >> of what? >> Of
disunityity. >> Meaning what? What do you mean by that?
>> Meaning that like a divided America is a broken America.
>> When has America been in the last
70 years? Where would America been one?
>> Uh, honor Jimmy Carter. There was
>> under Reagan. >> Hey, only one of these people
was alive under Jimmy Carter. I that feels like isn't that such
a weird thing to say under Jimmy Carter? It was very what? Huh?
Maybe hold she might mean united in their hatred of Jimmy Carter.
>> Maybe that is that what she means? >> Under there
was Yep. There's a lot of unity under Reagan. There was a fair
>> no one hated Carter. Okay, hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
Didn't Jimmy Carter have like massive negative appeal? Didn't
he like not even get back into his uh
I know nobody hates Jimmy Carter now, but wasn't he like the
least popular president ever? I'm being facicious. Oh, okay.
Okay. Okay. Okay. We're all on the same page then. I thought
people were trying to tell me that Carter was liked. >> Bit
of unity that emerged under Bush for a while. Like we we don't
achieve perfect unity for a >> It is true. Under Bush initially
there was a lot of uniting under him. The issue is that the Iraq
war became a major issue in his presidency and he had a lot of
fracturing not just from the left, from the right as well. Right.
So there has been great bouts of unity and I think it's good
when the country unites. Um >> what is Donald Trump doing?
But the country has not been united in a long time. Good and
evil would never unite
at
>> Uh sure. And they shouldn't. I just think that most
people are a mixture of both things. And a good leader aims to
pull out the good that exists. >> And you don't see Donald
Trump doing >> He's pretty antagonistic with anybody who
opposes him, including his own teams, right? Wants to fire.
>> Well, he wants to fire drone Powell, who he hired.
>> That guy is against Trump. He should get rid of his
enemies.
>> Why would you keep your enemy in your
Uh, just to be clear,
Jerome Powell, I think, was in before Trump was there. I'm almost
positive that Jerome Powell was already the head of the Fed when
Trump got there, right? Cuz he was printing all the money. I
remember all the memes. I don't remember. Am I crazy? Hold on.
Let me look it up.
Look it up. Jerome Pal, come on down. So, he's the He's the current
chair of the Federal Reserve Federal Reserve Board of Governors,
incumbent, 2012 under Obama. Oh, was he was he promoted assumed
office? No, no, no. It was under It was under Trump that he went
to the head the chair of the Federal Reserve. Got it. Okay. Okay.
Okay. I could have sworn that he was there beforehand, but nope.
He was he was there with Trump. >> I would certainly keep
them potentially people who counter my opinion. I would absolutely
keep on my business board, for example. Otherwise, you >> Trump
reappointed him. Oh, wait. What? Wait, what? Your enemies and
people who oppose you are some of the most gifted at seeing your
flaws and pointing out areas that you need. Of course, it is
>> I believe in having
in not just talk. >> Sorry, I need to back this up. I >> keep
on my business board, for example. Otherwise, you your enemies
and people who oppose you are some of the most gifted at seeing
your flaws and pointing out areas that you need. Of course, it
is true. No,
>> I believe in having in not just talking to people of
opposite viewpoints, but seeing the strengths of people >> talking
to people who have different viewpoints who criticize your flaws.
>> No, not like that. Talking to people who are like really
popular, who rep who are like very popular and have like totally
toxic viewpoints, who don't care about the future of America
at all. Like those people talking to those people.
>> Opposite view. Do you disagree that you shouldn't talk
to people of different >> No, you can talk to I talk to
anyone all the time anytime. But I would have if I know that
they're my
>> and I'm working to make things better and no way I keep
my enemy in my in my company. That doesn't make sense. Why does
that make sense to you? >> I think if everyone who disagrees
with you becomes an enemy, you're probably the common denominator.
>> See, that's why you can't have women as leadership.
They're emotional. But let me ask >> what's emotional about
that? um they can't make the right decision. You would keep your
enemy in your company and that makes sense to you. >> I
would keep my opposition. >> No, she wouldn't. No, she
wouldn't. She's just like you, JLP. She would tarnish them two
people privately behind the scenes and cry about them and never
talk to them. I don't know who she's presenting herself as right
now. >> Some other some other person. >> And that
makes sense to you to keep your enemy in your company. I would
definitely uh there's an old war law that you definitely want
to keep your enemy closest because you want to know what they're
up to. But I don't think what Yes. There's a very old proverb
that says keep your keep your friends close but keep your enemies
closer. Did you ever know this, JP? Keep your friends close but
keep your enemies
>> Is there such a thing as a warlock? What's a warlaw?
>> I don't I don't know a warlaw. >> You keep your
enemy in your company. >> Roman definitely. Uh there's
an old warlaw that you definitely want to keep your enemy closest
cuz you want to know what they're up to. >> There's an
old warlaw. I believe I an old warlaw. I don't She's talking
about Sunzu. Did Sunu say that? Keep your enemies close. Uh keep
your friends close but your enemies closer. Is that >> I
don't think your own power. >> Keep your enemy in your
company. >> Well, the issue is you're framing anyone who
disagrees with you as your enemy. I don't think somebody who
disagrees with me is my enemy. We're talking about this one particular
guy. >> Does it make sense to keep your enemy your company?
>> Well, it's it's your labor statistics. It seems like
everyone >> did not answer that question. >> Oh,
it's from the Godfather, too. But it is not from Sunzu
or Mchavelli. It's just from the Godfather, too. The
>> Sorry, what was your question? This
>> that's it's literally just the godfather to keep >> an
old war an old warlaw created by Michael Corleó >> your
enemy your company >> well it's it's your labor statistics
it seems like everyone >> did not answer that question
>> sorry what was your question >> this guy is Trump's
enemy
>> Jerome Powell >> and knowing that he is his enemy
should he keep him in his administration >> why is Jerome
Powell his enemy >> uh the the idea of keeping your enemy
close is something Sunzu talked about, but it is not where the
quotes from.
>> Why is Jerome Powell his enemy? >> Would you call
him friend? >> Uh, at least ally. Yeah, I think Jerome
Powell loves America and wants to see it thrive. I I think that
his economic leadership
he he's part of the major reason that we pulled out of CO economically
so strong. Drone Powell has believes in America.
Wait, isn't Jerome Powell like actually technically
super to blame for the the hot economy? Like not not exploring
like raising interest rates way faster than he did?
Like wouldn't he have actually been a huge cause of like the
heating up of the economy and [__] I think he's been
very good after that and it's easy to understand why with presidential
pre uh pressure he would keep interest rates low, but I think
he waited way too long to actually move because of the pressure.
So this might be an argument. He is friends, but I don't know,
man. I I feel like some of the problems with the co economy are
also laid at his feet as well. >> American. I mean, Trump
picked him. >> That's amazing.
>> Do you think that Trump picked wrong? Like Trump was
a fool when he picked wrong power. >> Let me ask, do you
agree with Trump that he shut the borders down and now the illegals
can't come in and he's shipping all the illegals back to wherever
they came from? You agree with that? Is there any way are you
going to answer my questions or is this only one way? If it is
only one >> she Okay, there you go. Somebody asked how
much time she put into prepping this right and there's the answer.
Zero because I have no idea
how in the world you did you really just say that Jesse Jesse
asked the questions. Okay, Jesse asked the questions. Nobody
else asked the questions here. >> Billy goes back to wherever
they came from. You agree with that? Is there any way we are
you going to answer my questions or is this only one way? If
it is only one way, that's okay. I just want to know. >> Do
you agree with Trump that he shut down the borders
and shipping the illegals back?
>> I think there was an immigration crisis and I think
the left
um laid in a big fat hammock neglecting it. So, immigration reform
was necessary. I >> Yeah, the left totally dropped the
ball on immigration, guys. Totally. >> They don't agree
with abandoning due
>> I actually believe that, but I do think for a lot of
the people that she's in a community with, that's that's a rough
>> Do you agree with the great white hope that he closed
the borders down and he's shipping illegals back to wherever
they came from? He's out there collecting them and shipping them
back. Do you agree with that? >> Uh the way that he's doing
it, uh by violating due process, no
illegals don't have due process in America. How can you be a
criminal in this country had due process? Doesn't even make sense.
>> Do you think that if I'm >> due process is for
citizens of the >> Nope. If I get murdered in America,
even if I'm a non-American citizen, >> that is that is
strictly not true. What JOP just said, okay, >> I still
get due process, right? My
>> Why was that?
Why was that her first example? If I get murdered, I don't why
not just pick an example where you could actually go through
the process yourself? I don't >> maybe she's about to say
her murderer will get due process. >> Yeah. I mean I that's
probably what she means. I'm just like dude why wouldn't you
just pick something like the immigrants? I don't >> still
can call the police. >> Can you be a criminal in this country
have due process? Doesn't even make >> Do you think that
if I >> due process is for citizens of the >> Nope.
If I get murdered in America, even if I'm >> Okay, she
did say if I get murdered >> non-American citizen, I still
get due process, right? My family still can call the police.
They'll still investigate who murdered me even if my murderer
was an American citizen. Right. This is obviously true. >> Are
you happy with the great white hope that he's sending he shut
the borders down and sending illegals back to the >> I'm
okay with the the borders being shut down. I disagree with removing
due process and >> and what it's actually the due process
here would be on the part of her murderer. The murderer would
have due >> She means she would still get justice.
>> She does, but it's just very it's just very funny. I
I think due process is a miracle of the American project. I think
it was >> Is it Wait, is it American in origin? The idea
>> she said a miracle >> of the American process
>> she calls it the American project, doesn't she? >> Well,
is it not based on like British law being shut down? I disagree
with removing due process. >> And why?
I I shut down and call the police. They'll still invest. >> Happy
with the great white hope that he's sending he's shutting the
borders down and sending illegals back to their >> I'm
okay with the the borders being shut down. I disagree with removing
due >> And why?
>> I I think due process is a miracle of the American project.
I think it >> I think due process is a miracle of the American
project. She always calls it a project and I I understand saying
that but the consistency to which she says it implies like this
project might be over soon. It's just temporary. This is a nice
little project. >> Maybe. But I sorry maybe I'm not even
paying attention to that cuz I can't get over the fact that she
says things that just sound good. All she does is try to say
things that sound good that sound like a good sound bite. I love
America. It's a miracle. Aren't we great as Americans? You're
Canadian, but aren't we great as Americans? We came up with due
process. It's like, no, you didn't. Why do you only speak in
platitudes about about how great America is without understanding
why you think any of the things you do? Is baffling.
>> Um, it's not really that baffling. This is her full-time
job. >> It's wild. Like, I think
I don't know. >> It was going a rarity. It's what America
led on in many ways. America and
>> uh Oh, I always say we when talking about the states.
Yeah, I do. Get over it, loser. >> The western development.
It's it's incredible being >> when did an illegal alien
that enter into our country illegally breaking the law get due
process >> because that's that's how the law works. And
I believe >> that doesn't work that way for criminals.
Illegals. >> Yes, it does. Criminals in America also
>> $3. It's a righteous project that will prevent people
from going scorched earth to earth in a nontological way. >> Thank
you very much, Ruben. Ruben, >> also isn't she Okay, correct
me if I'm wrong. If an immigrant comes over
and they are found without papers, they can claim asylum and
then for that they have to go through the justice system to qualify
or not. Like you can cross over illegally for a specific reason,
but you can't just be here illegally, make no claim, make no
announcement when you're caught and and think that you go through
the the due process system. No, you can just be deported. If
you say, "Oh, but I came here, sir. Sir, I just wanted to work
at my Taco Bell." No, you do have to go if you're not claiming
to be here for like a reason. >> Sure. You would need to
assert that you have a valid reason to be there, and then that
has to be adjudicated. If you don't make that claim, sure. >> Exactly.
So you Yeah. I But I'm not sure if she knows that. She's not
communicating that. >> Well, I don't know. I'm more
She's She might not be communicating that. I was listening to
I It sounded like she said something about innocent before guilty,
and I was like, there's no way she said that. It's It's incredible.
Being
>> This is This is a layered reaction. Okay. I to listen
to some of these statements multiple times. If you are an if
you are found without papers and you say that you're not legal,
what is the what needs to be found? >> Um, so you're found
without papers. You would need to be on the record having sought
asylum at the border, which most people could do fairly easily.
It's why they started going through. It depends on like when
you crossed and stuff as well. Um, but if they just find you,
you don't have papers and you have no like valid processing at
the border, I do believe they could just deport you. They might
have to do something to check into like any claims you make.
Like you are entitled to the you are entitled to due process
when you have some process you can go through or you have some
reason to be there. But yeah, I think you can just be deported
otherwise. >> Like if I grabs you and you're like, "No,
no, no. I'm a citizen.
I'm a citizen." Then yeah, you shouldn't just be deported. There's
a process. Like you have to give people the ability to prove
their citizenship. >> Well, you would have to be You would
be like, "Okay, can you give me your papers? Can you prove this
in any way?" Right? Like it's >> Yeah. if they can't. I
mean, I I don't know. I don't know.
it's on first encounter with law enforcement when you have to
claim asylum. Really? It's on first encount Dude, that's a crazy
that's a crazy law. >> Because the the implication is you
had to sneak into the country for dire
And so when law enforcement finds you, yes, I'm here, but it's
for asylum. >> I feel like you just worked for like four
years before having to do it. That's kind of I I feel like that's
wild, but it's whatever.
Okay. Interesting.
Very interesting. Yes. Due process is not always judicial. Sure.
>> Illegal alien that enter into our country illegally
breaking the law get due process >> because that's that's
how the law works. And I believe >> that doesn't work.
>> Oh, if they broke the law, they would still be entitled
to due process. like depending if somebody if somebody was an
illegal immigrant, they broke into the country and they somebody
to adjudicate that murder to like actually that would go through
a judicial process. You would have the right to due process.
You couldn't just be thrown in jail because you're uh an uh illegally
in the >> You also can't just get deported. I'm not Can
we not
make sure this is a is like guilty of what you found him doing?
Even if he is here illegally, if he's found guilty of the crime,
like if we you find an illegal alien was a Yeah. Put him through
the justice system and then lock him up. You don't get to be
a here and then go back to your country cuz you were illegal.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So Jesse saying they they're not given due
process. I would say I would assume that due process in a case
of an illegal immigrant committing like a low-level crime, like
let's say they were stealing something, right? It could be that
the due process there is checking making sure they're legal,
making sure they don't have any valid claims and then shipping
them out because you don't want to deal with having to process
them through your justice system, right? >> Normally they
would process you would put them you would incarcerate them.
You might incarcerate them and make them serve their time in
an ICE detention center and then you would deport them.
>> That way for criminals illegals. >> Yes, it does.
Criminals in America also get due process, right? You get assumed
assumed. He can put them on a plane, ship them back. He can pick
them up at Costco today, >> put them on a plane today,
and ship them right back where they came from, and he would be
right.
>> I think that's a violation of the American Constit.
>> But like, you don't want that, Jesse. Jesse, you don't
want that. You want them to go through a process that says how
they determine whether or not that person is legally here, whether
or not they have any claims to be here before you would send
them back. Right? You don't just want to You just don't want
to grab grab a bunch of brown people from Costco and send them
to another country. Like I I would assume another part of deporting
somebody is figuring out what country they're from.
>> It's not a violation for illegal alien. What the >> as
a as a Canadian, if I get >> See, this is why women shouldn't
be voted. They're too emotional. >> What's emotional about
this? >> You You're not making logical decisions.
>> How is that not logical? You think due process for illegal
due process? >> You think due process for criminals in
our country that came here illegally deserve criminals get due
>> under the constitution. They deserve due
>> So if I as a Canadian national am murdered in America,
do I get due process for justice for my murder? >> That's
not the subject that I'm asking about. I'm asking about illegal
aliens that come are you here illegally? >> Yeah. Yeah.
foreign.
>> Uh, what is the due process for a corpse? I don't know
what the due process is there. It's it's just such a weird
and it's like we know what she means kind of, but it's like I
don't know why she >> I'm not going to pretend like I know
what she means. >> Well, she's talking about like >> I
think she means to be in 4K and just get under all of she means
to put me in my personal hell right now. >> I don't know
why she picked this. She picked the worst example she could have
picked. She's not illegal either. She's just not a citizen. Even
illegal for >> she's doing she is doing >> technically
I don't know that but >> she's doing this to me and only
me
here illegally. Yeah. No, I understand. >> No, I am not
here illegally. >> So why would you apply that to you?
>> because you're saying that non-citizens don't get due
process or you're saying >> or you're saying that criminals
don't get due process, but both criminals and non-nationals get
due process. >> See, this is why women should not be running.
Well, I think I'm being more >> Just gaslight her, Jesse.
Just gaslight her heart and pretend you didn't say
>> Actually, hold on. Hold on. This is why she was so bad
at the women's right to vote thing. This is why she only wanted
to to make it about women making the wrong choice. She's defending
herself. She understands with every question. I'm going to get
the answer wrong. And that's why the the way that I defend women
is by saying women who get it wrong deserve autonomy. They deserve
agency. They deserve the right to vote. She defended herself
earlier for this moment right here. >> Yeah. Women have
the right to be Jesse.
>> And that's that's how I'm taking it >> Logical
than you right now. Right. You're saying illegal and non-citizens.
Illegal. So criminal action gets due process in America and non-citizens
get due process in America. So illegal non-citizens also presumably
by this is actually analytical philosophy. They also get due
process necessarily. say that the Constitution applies to people
who break into our country illegally. >> Typically, yeah.
Oh, for certain. Not all of the Constitution applies to them,
but things like due process does. >> No, it doesn't. >> Yes,
it does. >> Okay. See, let me ask
um I've said to and I I know a whole bunch of guys around the
world who have married and they wanted a family. So, a lot of
them end up marrying.
>> That might have been the most misogynistic thing. Jesse's
done this whole thing. Oh, what? How did he respond right there?
>> Yes, it does. >> Okay, see, let me ask.
>> Okay, see, he's like, I won. I want He just declared
victory. He just wanted to stop talking. Okay, see, and then
he just moves on. >> Um, I've said to and I >> He's
talking to his audience there, right? Okay. See? >> Okay.
Look, proof. I know a whole bunch of guys around the world who
have married and they wanted a family. So a lot of them end up
marrying women who are educated
and I suggest to them they should not marry an educated woman
because she doesn't make for a good wife and a mother and every
time it never fails every time they marry educated woman the
marriage go to hell in a hand basket. Do you agree with me that
a man should not marry an educated woman because she doesn't
make for a good wife and mother? >> I think educated marriages
last longer and have healthier children on average. So no, not
at all. That's not true. That's just what the data shows. >> Uhuh.
That's not true. Every man that if he stayed with her, he become
a beta man. She make him the woman and she go out and bring home
the bacon. >> Well, I would say that that's a failing on
both of those partners, right? Um, as a woman, you shouldn't
be deasculating your partner. And as a man, you also should not
be allowing your wife to deasculate you. So, if a deas >> any
deascators in chat,
>> Happening. I I think that's a >> woman that's
been educated. She thinks she's equal to a man and that she's
compete with him. She said she think that she would rather go
to work and get her ego strokes rather than stay at home and
and raise her children. And if she married a beta man, he'll
stay home and he become the wife and she become the
>> Uh I don't know what to tell you. The the the evidence
shows when you look at aggregate just like polls of demographics,
women that achieve higher levels of education have longer lasting
marriages and their children are typically they do. >> Women
with education
way quicker than nonwomen
with no education. But let me ask >> in general in general
why even >> to be fair guys he's talking about a high school
education.
I actually don't know what he's saying. >> But why even
make this uh why even rest on this? Because the whole point of
feminism is that you give women the ability to get a divorce
because like
marriage isn't the determination for happiness. It's not like
that's not a tradition that you have to be beholden to. She's
holding this
this stat to like this outcome. I don't know. Just >> that's
I find that's most of the time she's like confident in something
which she could point to like uh >> look at this data.
Look at the length of these relationships.
>> It seems to be now that's not necessarily wrong, but
I do find it weird that she can't sometimes. >> What does
that data communicate? Not not necessarily what you want it to
>> I don't know what it Yeah. I I mean I don't know what
the data is. So I I would have to take her word for it and I'm
not inclined to do that most of the
>> right? So I >> Well, I'm not saying if the if
it's wrong or not. Let's say her data is correct. Educated women
stay in marriages longer. >> Does that make that a happier
marriage? Does that make that a marriage with more children?
Does that make that >> She said healthier children was
the other one, I think. So no, not necessarily. But
>> I don't know what that says. >> Doesn't know the
data either. Okay. Well, poverish tend to often be a little bit
more impulsive. Their relationships fail at a significantly higher
way than non women with no education. But let me >> in
general in general people in impoverish tend to often be a little
bit more impulsive. Their relationships fail at a significantly
higher rate. They also have a much lower marriage. Right? People
who are less educated typically don't get married are having
children out of wedlock and therefore can't even qualify in the
marriage statistics because they were never married in the first
place. They just have like multiple children with different men.
That's typically what we're seeing with like the lesser educated
>> bringing him right to the welfare
>> oh. Now again
all this
really making up all this stuff. >> You can just Google
it. >> Oh why are you making this up? >> You can
just Google it. >> Google it. What the >> Yeah, just
look it up. Yeah, go look at the stats. >> So let me ask
because of time. >> What the What is it? What has >> What
the What? What the >> Donald Trump done or doing that you
think is amazing. >> Um I think his child tax credit was
really good. >> Uh if you needed any more proof that Jesse
Lee Peterson is a Fuentes watcher. Okay. What the >> I
loved the child tax credit. I think in general making it more
affordable to have children.
Very good thing to do. >> Are you going to have children?
>> Yeah. Yeah. >> Do you support abortion?
>> I I support the legal access to abortion. It's probably
the wrong thing to do on average. It's probably more noble to
not, but I think the societal impacts of not uh allowing abortions
is >> So, you do support abortion
>> I didn't ask if you support it legally, that mean you
support it.
>> what's the difference?
>> Uh my faith is not the same thing as my politics.
till your faith tell you you could support a child in the >> So
is he there's
>> legally but if a woman decide to go in the alleyway
and kill a child you don't support that? >> Well I would
say that when she does it legally it's probably the worst choice
and it would be more good to keep it but I would like her to
have the legal access to make that choice. So you support the
woman the baby the man's baby in the womb legally
>> and her baby >> to be fair >> it's not her
baby it's his baby >> what why would Oh sorry I've never
heard why would he make that I don't understand why he makes
that correction both she's Garing >> how does she both
sides abortion like this I cuz she is trying to upset us okay
I talk >> she's too moral theory just >> yeah I could
just hear Son like I in my head Son is like revving up right
does not like.
>> So you support the the woman the baby legally but not
going doing it uh in alleyway or
illegally. >> I've never seen
this is what will always baffle me. I don't see women do this
sort of content online without selling like the shameless consistent
like don't even crack or don't break sort of rage bait. I don't
see them doing that without like also selling >> the lab
model. Yeah.
>> There there are better ones from whatever than Lav,
but I that's the only person I know personally. >> If Arodite
actually sold I would be less offended at this.
>> That makes sense. >> I would actually
I would like her because then that's just funny. This act she
just seems cruel to me.
>> Like like there's just no She's just doing it for the
love of the game.
>> I'm the person who makes fun of Haitians and dirt cookies.
She seems cruel to me. This is inhumane.
>> Uh, I'm sorry. What are illegal? What are your illegal
abortions? >> You said you support the long as it's legal,
you okay with her the baby in the
>> Yes, I support women's access to >> So, you do
support abortion then? >> No, I think it's typically the
worst choice, but overall, I think it's a choice that women should
have access. >> Why? Just
Yes. Yes, you support abortion. You could say, "Yes, I support
abortion because I think it." You can say everything else, but
you don't say, "No, I don't support abortion." You do support
it. I
Let's keep going. >> That's amazing.
>> Did you know that 70% of divorces
of are being filed by women?
>> Now, we like stats. Hey, >> and so >> we
like to pick and choose when we likes stats, don't we? But >> that's
not good. Not good. >> But so how more marriage working
better with educated women is 70% of them are filing for abortion.
I mean for divorce >> first of all typically uneducated
women are not getting married. They tend to common law for a
long time and then separate. So they're not getting included
in the stats. >> We're not we talk about the ones that
are getting married.
>> Right. Well, you're talking about educated versus uneducated,
and I'm saying one of the issues in the uneducated category is
they're getting married less often. They common law more >> We're
talking about the ones that are getting married and divorcing.
>> Yep. And so educated, I think it's not just educated
women. I think women overall initiate divorce
than men. >> This report says 70% of divorces are being
filed by women.
If you don't trust my stats, how am I supposed to trust yours?
>> Do you trust that? >> I don't know. Where's your
source from >> the sources? >> Because you didn't
trust mine. So, it's it's going to be tough to If you get to
use stats and I take it for granted, but when I use stats, you
just say, "Huh, that's made up. Now, we're at an impass.
You get to use something I don't." >> You're just saying
stuff that you don't even know what you're talking. >> I
I wish Okay. If if Jesse was on his feet four years ago, Jesse
would have had the perfect comeback there. Yeah, you're a woman.
I don't of course I don't trust you. That's like my entire right,
he would have said that, but he's a little slow right now. He's
saying, "You're just throwing stuff out." >> You could
have the devil. That's what he would say. >> You're a woman.
>> saying you could have just typed up stuff on me. It
could have just made something up. I'm willing to grant it. The
issue is I'm looking for you to grant me stats in return. Right.
>> Okay. I'll let you ask.
Do you believe racism exists?
>> I'm sorry.
>> And what's your proof? >> Uh racist. I think for
example, black men tend to go to jail for longer for the same
crimes that white men will get reduced sentences for is a good
example. >> And why is that?
>> Oh my god. Wait. Someone someone get that clip and then
just stop it right after she says for example black men.
Just right there, stop it, please. And thank you.
>> It's very odd to say if you are black again, we can
hold it. If you want stats, since you said you'll get me stats,
when we look at actually forensic recidivism data, even when
you hold, for example, number of priors between white men and
black men, the same, black men on average still get sentenced
to a significantly longer time. In the same way that if you hold
the men's statistics consistent with priors to a woman's, even
if a woman has 14, you know, um, reference to the Ukrainian 14
prior and the man has 14 prior, she'll get a much lesser sentence
typically. I just think that there's prejudice in the way that
we stereotype people. So, do you think that if the black man
that committed the crime was a will
pay a lawyer to represent him, maybe he wouldn't go to jail as
much as he would does by getting a free lawyer from the courts?
Whereas white men tend to pay for their lawyer. So, they're going
to get the best lawyer when they have to go to court ask for
a free lawyer. That lawyer is, I mean, busy with so many cases.
Uh, he doesn't really have time to try to figure it out. If white
men were a if black men were able to pay for their own lawyers
in the way that white men are able to do, do you think it would
be even play then? >> Um I suspect no. >> Um I'm
pretty sure that Well, I'm pretty sure the data has already looked
into this that even when you look at economic status, so essentially
people's economic access to better lawyers, even then
the black men will get sentenced longer specifically. So they
often will get off of You just got me. Judge Judy just got me.
You got me. That was Cuffam with >> You got me. That was
Cuffam. >> Uh, some dude's putting like nudes in the chat
or something, but then the other one was Cuffam. Okay.
Fortunately, we have to we have to allow Wait, the other one
was Ralph. Okay, I'm sorry. I can't tell that. Oh god, that is
Ralph. Gross. Never use those in this chat again or you will
be permitted. Okay. Ever. Ever.
Ever. Sorry, I had to stop for those. It's gross. People are
gross. Do not use those in my chat. Get the [__]
out of >> The same rate because they have a similar quality
lawyer, but the judge gets to decide the length, right? And often
time judges will just opt for longer, more steeper sentences
for black men than for white men. >> Not true. When black
men pay for their own lawyers,
that lawyers on their case in the same way a white man when he
pays for his lawyer, they're going to get the same thing most
of the time. >> I'm not sure if that's true. >> No,
it is true. I don't know if I believe you. >> Well, do
you have any proof that racism
>> I just gave you one. Yeah. >> No, that's not proof.
>> Well, we just talked about how it is. And I'm not granting
you you making up facts either. Right. So, an impass. >> Amazing.
Do you have any other proof that racism exists?
>> Uh, yeah, sure. I think uh an important question to
you, for example, why is it the case that black men typically
can't afford a more expensive lawyer when a white man can? because
they believe the
>> Subutai, you have the right to freedom of speech here,
but spamming your opinions repeatedly is enough to get you timed
out for the day. Come back tomorrow. Try again. >> That
they can't make it because they're
>> White people are superior to them, so they'll be blaming
and >> trying to get something free rather than earning
their own way. >> So, you think that black people just
try less hard?
>> do you think black people just try less hard than white
people to make money? No, they need to get out and just do it.
They don't need to try any harder or less, but just do it. >> So,
black people just don't
like go to jobs or like try to make money. >> Some do,
most don't because they have they they've heard that they can
get it free. All they have to do cry racism and they can get
it free. Do you love white
>> Yeah. Yeah. >> I didn't I didn't hear you. >> What?
I'm sorry. That's
>> he's freezing.
>> I didn't I didn't hear you. >> Yeah. Yes. I like
white people. >> You love white people?
>> Oh, nice.
Um, you are a Christian, right?
>> God said that our battle is not physical, it's spiritual.
That we wrestle not against flesh and blood, but against spirits
and wickedness
uh in high places evil. Why do you call it racism
rather than calling it good or >> I I Dude, you never know.
You never know if Jesse's
>> I can't tell, man. >> Why do you call it what
the world call it rather than
this is Judge Judy kid
has man boobs
aren't illegal? >> They're just my body is like trying
to protect me and so I like shut off my ears sometimes when she's
talking. But she really did say, "Oh, well, my example for racism
is sometimes black people can't afford things."
>> Uh,
I don't think that was exactly it. Although it's happening to
me a little bit, too. I was dealing with the chat. I think it
was her first example was black people get higher punishments
for the same crimes. >> No, no. After that, after she said,
>> and then after he said, >> "Why can't black people
afford really good lawyers?"
she said that or he said that. >> She said that. >> Okay.
What did he say in response? And then she said something about
you think that black people aren't trying to get jobs or
it's like she's finding the worst ways to argue
that racism exists. Like she's pretty pretty racist with her
examples.
>> I feel like this podcast is proof that racism exists.
>> Yeah. You could have just said, "Oh, well you Jesse
>> Yeah, I
what God's call >> you're pretty racist. You think it's
the great white hope. What does him being white have to do with
it, Jesse?
>> Yeah. Also, the great white hope is Christian McAffrey.
But,
>> Donald Trump being a white president, the great white
hope. All the presidents a bit white. Okay. Except one.
Christian McAffrey is like the NFL's Obama. All right. That's
just how it is. >> Mostly for specificity. I think if we
called just everything that's bad evil and everything that's
good good and those were the only words we had, we'd never know
what we're talking about. >> Why? And I just have to be
like, "Well, black people have bad things happen to them." And
you'd be like, "What kind of bad things?" And I'd be like, "The
baddest of bad like bad things, right?" Just for specificity.
I think racism is immoral, obviously. But I call it racism for
specific. >> Why don't you call it what God called it rather
than calling it something else? Are you saying that God didn't
know what he was doing when he called it good versus evil? >> No.
I I these are not separate things, right? Something can be good
and evil and also something else, right?
can be good and evil and also something else. Oh god, she's going
to remove the um the unlawful part of murder here, isn't she?
She's going to do I've heard her I feel like I've heard her do
this before. Please, for the love of God, do not do murder is
murder in society, but actually it's moral in war. Please don't
do that. Please don't do that. Please don't do that. >> No,
it's either good or evil, not nothing else. >> Do you think
murder is good or evil?
You're not answering the question. Why do you call it something
other than what God calls it? >> I'm answering your question
with a question back to kind of elucidate my point because I
did answer it. I just don't think you're understanding me. >> I
said that God does not call it racism. He call it good versus
evil. And as a daughter of God, why don't you call it what your
father call it? Why do you call it what the children of Satan
calls it? for the same reason that I call murder murder instead
of just evil for
>> Yeah. So, we know what we're talking >> So, is
murder done
due to racism or >> Sometimes evil and then sometimes it's
for racism, sometimes it's for greed, and sometimes it's for
uh vengeance. There's all sorts of evils that contribute to murder,
>> but it's always evil that's influencing it, right? >> Sure.
Yeah. I agree that racism is evil, though. I've already said
that. >> But how can it be evil when it doesn't exist?
It's just a word made up by evil >> A little bit here.
>> I guess you and I disagree about whether it exists or
not. So, if you don't think it exists, then it doesn't matter.
>> At least she's not bouncing her like she does in her
clips, says Ginger. Ginger, you have no idea. Okay, Ginger. At
some point, she tried to stretch her back to get her chest onto
the screen, which is particularly impressive given how high up
the camera lens is. Okay. >> And if I She's trying to be
uh Christian here, so >> Mhm. I would label it evil. >> Do
you have white privilege? >> I'm sure people would say
that I do. >> What do you say? >> Uh probably in
in some areas. There's definitely some things where if I show
up next to my husband, my my husband's a quarter Nigerian. Um
it smooth. >> You married to a black man? >> I am.
Yeah. >> You m Well, no wonder. >> That's how you
know I'm so cool, right?
>> Well, they are both laughing for incredibly different
reasons. >> Way different reasons. >> Way different
reasons right now. >> That explain it all. >> Sorry.
That makes sense now. Why you think the way you think? >> Does
it? >> Yeah. But >> I mean submissive to >> He's
like not going to elaborate. It's going to torture her now. He
just got her so badly. He knows he's never going to elaborate
on that. He just goes, "It's all explained now." And then he's
going to continue and then going to [__] with her.
>> That's now why you think the way you >> Does it?
>> Yeah. But >> am I being submissive to the wrong
type of man? Is that what you're saying? >> No, I'm not
saying that. I didn't I didn't know you're married to a black
man, but it makes sense now that you would think that way.
He's conservative. >> No, it makes sense that you would
think that way. >> But he's conservative. He knows it makes
sense that you I'm talking about you. I didn't say him. I don't
know anything about him. So
Jesse Lee Pearson will go down the How does she not know this?
He's going to say, "Oh, your husband's black. That's why he lets
you take charge because they were raised by women because their
fathers left the household. They don't have a masculine role
model. So it makes sense that he would want a masculine woman."
You don't know the trees of Jesse Lee Peterson? >> Apparently,
she doesn't know him. >> But if I'm submissive to my husband
and I like take a lot of like leadership and opinion from him
and he's conservative, why would it I guess what does it mean
when you say it makes sense? >> I told you it's going to
kill her. It's actually going to kill her. Him not elaborating.
Oh, he
Oh, I could I could just see it the second the second he said
it. >> I think right. >> We call you Mar.
What does that mean?
>> That that's why you think the way you think and you
believe racism is is and and all that mess.
>> Well, that's fine. I'm not to be fair. He probably disagrees
on the extent to which I would say it exists, right? >> He's
conservative. He's conservative. Thank you. >> So, listen.
I got to put you on the hot seat. I need you to answer these
questions as quickly as possible.
>> Oh, let me ask. Do you have anger?
>> I think I already said we we talked about this. Uh,
yes, >> you do have anger. Yep. >> They all have
anger. >> What would happen if you dropped your anger and
never got angry again about
>> Um, I would be better in most ways and probably ungodly
in some ways. >> Oh, you would be ungodly in some way without
anger. >> Well, we talked about this, right? Like Christ
Jesus himself had righteousness. >> Oh, yeah. You said
you said that. You're right. So, listen. I got to put you on
the hot seat. >> I need you to answer these as quickly
as
>> What is love? >> That's sick production value.
Ooh. Giving people things that you don't want to give them, they
don't want to receive and accepting it. Anyways, >> is
America the best country on this side of heaven?
>> Do we need more white babies?
>> Yeah, sure. >> What is a man? >> Uh, a
XY chromosome having hair, breast lacking, bearded human being
who probably sits with his legs spread and likes prototypically
sports, but not always. Um,
>> you are you're a man. >> Did you take the jab?
>> Yeah, I was a first responder. I worked in addiction.
So, >> true or false? When she's crying, she's lying. True
or false?
>> I'm sorry.
>> Do you um do you keep hot sauce in your in your purse?
>> In my purse?
>> No. Which would you rather uh have as
>> Justin Trudeau or Donald Trump?
>> You're really okay. Okay.
>> Okay. I She just got I just participated in her king.
She wants everybody to call her and I just did it. It's so Are
you
>> Justin Trudeau. >> Like she she has to understand
that even faking the hesitancy there. I dude >> or Donald
Trump. Ooh, you're really You don't like me, do you? >> I
love you. I'm really I love you. >> I don't know either.
I don't like >> That's so It's so fake. It has to be so
fake. You're literally I'm sorry. That clip right there is all
of the Pik Me arguments. Anybody who calls her a Pik me who says
that this is like a grift. This is the clip you would use to
just show Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely a grift. Absolutely. Just a
total grift. There's no reason to take this person seriously.
That's horrible. Like, is she not following anything going on
in politics? I literally can't keep up. We can't keep up with
politics right now because of all of the illegal and unconstitutional
and morally like just totally morally or sorry, totally immoral
behavior of Donald Trump. Like, we actually can't keep up. And
she goes, "Well, you know, Justin, I think he like took some
money from he took some money from some questionable places once.
He wore blackface once. >> This is a you thing. That's
Canada. I absolutely don't know what he did. Tr I don't like
Justin Trudeau, but like to compare him to Trump, compare him
to Trump is just insane. >> Oh, yeah. Obviously insane.
>> Yeah, I don't like Justin Trudeau, but it's like I'm
sure I I'm sure I wouldn't have liked uh who like um
I'm sure I wouldn't have liked, you know, HW Bush. I don't I
don't know anything about his presidency, but I'm sure I wouldn't
have liked him, but like obviously I would just pick him immediately
over Trump. >> Think he was like
>> I'm aware that he was corrupt. I'm aware he did wrong.
He's the one who like made promises. I'm going to cut taxes and
then he increased them. I think that's why he had a bad rep.
I'm pretty sure. >> George Bush's dad, >> I think.
So, somebody can correct me if I'm wrong.
>> Yeah. He said no new taxes and then there were new taxes.
>> White people just lie right to your >> He also
invaded Panama, right?
Also invaded Panama. Dude, you cannot say she's from Alberta.
You cannot say she's from Alberta. There is just no way you can
evaluate Justin Trudeau as a as a leader and say Donald Trump
is like better. You you have to have if you are anywhere near
her sphere of politics
and you are exposed to information we know she is. There is no
way you can compare Donald Trump to another world leader right
now. Another world leader in a western democracy. Maybe maybe
Orban. Maybe you could compare him to Orban or >> Her whole
platform is about we need to take care like do something about
Trump,
>> but now it's like up in the air. That's what I'm saying.
I I feel like she looking for a new team to be on. >> I
That was just such a weird argument. If any province No, Albertans
have that take Canadian color. She has to think Albertans are
harmful the same way she thinks Republicans are harmful. It is
the same brain. >> Have you Have you considered that she's
just not thinking? >> I probably should. So, you should
>> Which would you prefer if you had to make a choice?
>> This is after ketamine therapy. >> They're both
so corrupt. It is >> gun to my head. Probably Trudeau.
>> Amazing. Again, that's gun to my head. Okay. I'm not
opting for either. >> Right on. >> I might take the
bullet. I might take the bullet. >> Trust me. I I don't
like Justin Trudeau. I think he was like overall terrible as
a prime minister. I think he was. But it's not close. >> Is
it ever okay to call a woman fat? >> Both so corrupt. No.
Do Justin Dustin Trudeau was corrupt. He was not even in the
same stratosphere. He was not in the same universe as Donald
Trump. There's a whole universe between him and Donald Trump
in terms of corruption.
>> Uh yeah, it depends on like how you're doing it, but
yeah. >> Which is worse, abortion or slavery?
>> Okay. She she had to think about that for a second and
it's like you just argued that you wouldn't make abortion illegal.
So you have to you have you already answered this. Oh, that that
that pause to think >> which is worse, abortion or slavery?
>> Is the earth flat or round?
>> It's round. >> Did you have fun? >> That
was an easy one. At least >> that was easy. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Thank you so much for having >> It's round. >> Oh,
did you have fun? >> Did you have fun? >> I did.
Thank you so much for having me. >> It was an honor to
have you. I enjoyed talking to you. Really? >> Thank you.
Good. I enjoyed talking to >> Tell the people how they
can get your YouTube channel, your whatever you want to put out
there. >> Sure. Uh I'm Twitter, Tik Tok, Instagram, everywhere.
Not so arudite. That's spelled e r u d i t e. Um you can check
me out. I've got a nuance liberal takes with a little bit of
radicalism wherever you need.
>> Well, thanks for coming on. >> A little bit of
radicalism wherever you need it. She literally is just like an
advertisement cuz none of that makes >> Have you considered
that she's just not >> be radical wherever you need it
for the right amount of money.
>> And thank you all for tuning in. I absolutely appreciate
it. Don't forget to like, follow, ring the bell, support us by
becoming me. >> Ring the bell. I've been told that this
clip is critical. Okay, so she reacted to her own interview tonight.
I've been told that this clip is critical. >> Thank you
for having me. >> What's important to you?
>> That's a good question. Um, my husband, uh, my faith
and trying to conduct
well.
So, I as soon as he asked me that question, I didn't expect it,
but I was like, "Oh, I know. I'm going to be subversive." My
favorite thing that I do on Fresh and Fit is I like subvert expectations
because they're like, "You've only had sex with one person and
that's your husband." And I'm like, >> "Why is your first
This is like, >> yeah." And >> I don't believe I
don't believe it. How many women do we see in this space pretend
like they haven't had sex with this person? No, I only have with
this person. No, I didn't sleep my way to the top. I don't believe
any of you. >> None of you. You got a trip to Israel, then
you got like faked. I don't believe any of you are not [__]
around.
>> I just don't understand that. I'm I'm going to be subversive.
Like, I'm just going to lie. Like, wouldn't you just want Aren't
you trying to find the people who would like you, who would connect
with your content?
>> Why are you like, "Oh, I'm just going to lie." And then
which part did you lie about? You said, "My husband, my faith.
I'm going to be subversive. I maybe I have to I might have to
let it play a little bit more. But it's like why would you say
>> I read
book? It's literally what's most important to you? Why would
your first response to that question, first thought be I'm going
to be subversive? Why wouldn't it just be I'm going to say what's
important to me. I don't I don't understand.
I know. I'm going to be subversive. My favorite thing that I
do on Fresh and Fit is I like subvert expectations because they're
like, "You've only had sex with one person and that's your husband."
And I'm like, "Yeah." And they're like, "And you like trust him
and look up to him and like are obedient or whatever." And I'm
like, "Yeah." And they're like, "That's awesome. Don't you hate
these other horrors?" And I'm like, "No,
that's stupid." And me, my life is not all it's cracked up to
be. It's just filled with lots of shame, vaginismas, and problems.
And
but uh what what why did you just Why? >> You keep preaching
what you want. I love being subversive. Okay. So I I lean >> That's
what did she subvert? What expectation did she subvert? Do you
think these people sincerely want women to be happy? When you
go fresh and fit, you think Myron actually believes I want my
wife to be submissive to me. First of all, you believe he wants
wife, but you expect that he actually wants women to be happy.
That's his goal. He wants women to be everything he needs and
nothing that requires anything from him as much as possible.
That's what he wants. He's not going, "Oh, he doesn't care about
how happy you He's not saying he wants you to be religious or
faithful or uh honoring him or submissive because he wants you
to be happy. That's not that's not the actual argument. >> I
don't even know what's happening. I'm
Can you transfer it? I don't know what she's saying. Hooligans
and I don't want to know. The more I hear about her, the more
I regret making the YouTube series that I did because
I ever took this person seriously. you made a YouTube series
on somebody who has not quite realized yet that they were JLP.
>> I was like, what is wrong with this person? I couldn't
get to the bottom of it. There's something inauthentic about
her. And lo and behold,
it's just a waste of time. Just a waste of time. It was cathartic
though making the video, but also just a waste of time. And I
don't want to dissect her any further than that. I'm just going
to wait until she continues to stick her head probably where
it doesn't belong. Uh, well,
I just
I kind of thought that at somewhere along the way here, she I
at this point I gotta say I hope the ketamine therapy worked
because
if I remember correctly, she said she was like having severe
like depression problems before and she's going on places now.
She said she had severe depression problems. I think she blamed
like some of the bullying that was happening to her, what she
perceived as bullying online, but she's just going and going
to like overshare everywhere now. I hope it worked. I hope it
works because you're like trying to get yourself bullied now,
which is just an odd choice.
>> Yeah, I don't know. >> Every time I overshare,
it's like a I can't even help it when it comes out. It's like
out of fear or something. I don't understand making the decision
>> calculated decision. >> The calculated decision
like this is how I can win people over. I had something on the
tip of my tongue. I forgot. >> Okay, I
thank God we made it. We made it to the end.